bonjour à tous et merci d'être venus si
nombreux pour assister à cette septième
édition des matinales de la transition
écologique au sein de centrale nantes
pour expliquer en quelques mots ce que
sont les matinales il s'agit d'un cycle
de conférences organisé par les élèves
avec une nouvelle équipe tous les ans
cette année elle est composée de antoine
kalyan louise pierre et moi même et
messieurs benguigui et rosières ont tenu
tout d'abord à remercier l'équipe de
l'année précédente qui nous a permis
d'accueillir monsieur jancovici
aujourd'hui donc les matinales c'est
quoi il s'agit d'inviter des
personnalités de spécialité et
d'horizons différents pour venir
présenter une opinion et des idées sur
des questions de transition écologique
le but est de vous présenter et les
membres de l'école mais aussi personnes
extérieures un point de vue assumer et
en débattre pour réfléchir ensemble à
ces questions fondamentales
nous avons pu aborder dernièrement les
thématiques d'économie circulaire avec
jean-michel l'uff de décroissance avec
vincent liegey ou encore d'écologie
politique avec le député matthieu
orphelin
vous pouvez d'ailleurs retrouver toutes
ces conférences sur la chaîne youtube de
l'école
aujourd'hui nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir jean marc jancovici il est
notamment co fondateur de carbone 4 un
cabinet de conseil spécialisé sur la
transition écologique et l'adaptation au
changement climatique et il est
président du think-tank de chips projet
monsieur jancovici est également membre
du haut conseil pour le climat organisme
chargé d'émettre des recommandations sur
la mise en oeuvre des politiques et
mesures publiques pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de la
france monsieur joe cole ici nous
proposera donc au regard de son
expérience
une lecture de la relation entre l'homme
et l'énergie dans nos sociétés cette
conférence sera organisée en deux temps
avec tout d'abord l'intervention de
monsieur jancovici
puis nous enchaînerons avec un temps de
questions réponses n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions pendant ce temps des
changes
car malheureusement nous serons pris par
le temps il nous contraint d'arrêter la
conférence à l'heure d'ailleurs à ce
sujet pour les personnes qui sont en
rediffusion dans l'amphi s vous pouvez
poser vos questions via le lien qui est
inscrit sur le tableau où sur l'écran en
face de goût mais avant de commencer
cette conférence nous aimerions prendre
quelques minutes
pour considérer cette question de
transition écologique au sein même de
notre école
j'aimerais donc passé la parole à deux
élèves victor et josé
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous tout d'abord
merci à monsieur jancovici et à l'équipe
des matinales de nous permettre de
prendre la parole en introduction de
cette conférence alors nous sommes josé
rondelle et victor blanquart étudiant en
deuxième année ici astrale vous avez
peut-être entendu parler de la lettre
ouverte à notre futur directeur future
directrice
cette lettre dresse le constat des
problématiques socio environnemental et
on l'a ouverte à la signature afin que
les personnes
qui partagent nos idées puissent
démontrer avec nous que ces
problématiques ne sont plus la sphère
d'une minorité
ensuite avec cette lettre que nous
allons envoyer aux candidates c'est aux
candidats nous joindrons des questions
alors c'est des questions forcément en
lien avec les problématiques socio
environnemental des questions auxquelles
nous avons peut-être une idée de réponse
mais nous ne voulons pas influencer les
candidates et candidats
donc nous allons leur envoyer ces
questions et ensuite on débattra avec
les réponses qui nous auront donné et
comme ça on pourra mieux construire les
solutions va co construire des solutions
et on pourra aboutir un meilleur
résultat
donc je vais laisser josé prendre la
parole qui va vous lire cette lettre
intitulée pour un directeur pour une
directrice engagé et voilà le pour
signer la lettre ouverte voilà vous avez
le qr code ici
à la suite de la démission du précédent
directeur de l'école centrale de nantes
et compte tenu du contexte actuel nous
étudiantes et étudiants
ce ton faire entendre notre voix auprès
de vous sa successeuse ou son successeur
l'enseignement dispensé par centrale
nantes se doit d'être en accord avec les
enjeux d'aujourd'hui et de demain
notre formation de nous permettre de
réfléchir et d'agir en tant qu'ingénieur
et citoyennes et citoyens éclairés et
conscients tu es conscient du monde qui
nous entoure
l'incohérence qui existe entre le
contenu des formations et logeant socio
environnemental est à l'image des
aveuglements global l'humain aux dépens
de sa survie provoque un dérèglement
climatique exploitent les ressources non
renouvelables jusqu'à leur épuisement
perturbe profondément l'écosystème et
menace la biodiversité d'une sixième
extinction nous étudiantes et étudiants
ce ton que nos études nous apporte les
outils et les connaissances nous
permettant d'affronter nos craintes et
de répondre question aux questions
auxquelles nous faisons face les valeurs
fortes qui nous anime et nous guide ne
peuvent être mises en arrière-plan de
nos formations
elles sont la base de nos motivations
la structure de nos forces et le liant
nos objectifs nous sommes formés à faire
émerger des idées des solutions mais pas
à réfléchir au sens de ce que nous
produisons cela est pourtant primordiale
compte tenu des impacts sociaux
engendrés et des limites planétaires
l'école est un écosystème dans lequel
nous vivons et nous grandissons nous en
sommes ainsi responsable en particulier
dans le choix de ses orientations
politiques
notre voeu est simple mobiliser des
moyens à la hauteur de l'urgence
écologique est un signe ici un virage
radical au sein de l'école centrale de
nantes mais l'exaucer ne l'est pas il
faut prendre
libéré le temps nécessaire à la
réflexion pour construire un nouveau
modèle de société
ce virage nécessite beaucoup de courage
d'audace et d'énergie sachez cependant
que vous ne serez pas seul d'année en
année nous constatons l'accélération des
prises de conscience et de l'engagement
des étudiantes et étudiants en faveur de
la transition écologique et solidaire
nous serons à vos côtés animé par des
convictions profondes
nous avons un besoin urgent de
transformer notre modèle en profondeur
êtes vous prêts êtes vous prêt à relever
ce défi avec nous
[Applaudissements]
merci victor merci josé malheureusement
nous n'aurons pas le temps de plus
débattre ici de cette lettre il nous
semblait toutefois important de laisser
la parole aux élèves sur ce sujet
fondamental en espérant qu'ils trouvent
un écho chez nombre d'entre vous sans
plus attendre
passons maintenant la parole à joe
messieurs jean marc jancovici pour la
conférence en tant que tel votre
conférence
[Applaudissements]
or
bon maintenant que la petite annonce a
été publiée on va donner le cahier des
charges bonjour à toutes et à tous alors
je quelques précisions avant de démarrer
cette intervention la première c'est que
je présente mes plus plates excuses et
mes sincères condoléances aux lycéens
pour la raison suivante c'est que j'ai
prévu de calais mon discours sur les
étudiants
donc de temps en temps il ya un petit
truc que vous comprendrez pas ce que je
vous suggère c'est de noter
soigneusement sur une feuille de papier
et d'aller en kaki des votre prof de
physique ensuite en lui demandant ce que
j'ai bien pu raconter
la deuxième chose que je vais dire donc
je présente tout autant mes plus plates
excuses et mes sincères condoléances aux
gens qui ne sont pas des élèves de
l'école au ce matin je m'en fiche
après c'est pas à eux d'en jeu je vois
là donc je vais m'adresser
essentiellement aux élèves de l'école et
donc je vais commencer à m'adresser aux
élèves de l'école en leur disant que ce
que je vais vous présenter maintenant on
rentre dans un cadre un peu plus général
qui est le suivant vous êtes rentré ici
en ayant été soigneusement sélectionnés
sur votre aptitude à résoudre des
problèmes bien posée qui n'admettent
qu'une seule solution corps c'est de
cette manière que vous êtes rentré ici
donc on vous a donné des primes bien
poser toute l'information qui vous
permettait de résoudre le problème était
dans l'énoncé est le problème n'admet
qu'une solution corps
ce dont je vais vous parler maintenant
c'est d'un problème posé de travers qui
admet plein de solution est soit dit en
passant tout ce que vous trouverez dans
votre vie professionnelle en règle
générale ça se présente comme ça c'est
des problèmes mal posée qui admettent
plusieurs solutions
voilà donc vous avez quelques années
d'étude pour comprendre comment
exploiter à votre profit votre aptitude
à résoudre des problèmes bien posée qui
n'admettent qu'une seule solution pour
vous mettre au travail sur des problèmes
posés de travers qui en a fait plusieurs
et ce que je vais vous évoquez ce matin
c'est un cas parmi d'autres alors il est
particulièrement important à mes yeux
mais c'est un cas parmi d'autres d'un
problème posé de travers avec man
solution
ce que je vais également essayé de faire
c'est de vous rappeler des faits vous
savez que dans les débats il y a les
faits et il y a les opinions il est
souhaitable quand on souhaite ne pas se
créer son propre malheur de bien faire
la différence entre les deux est de ne
pas recommencer à débattre indéfiniment
des faits et de se contenter de débattre
des opinions par exemple on peut
débattre du fait que la terre est ronde
si ça nous amuse c'est juste une perte
de temps d'accord alors faites attention
parce que dans la presse il adore faire
ça il adore mélanger les faits et les
opinions et faire re débattre à l'infini
de fait établi qu'ils aiment beaucoup
thèse antithèse
en général quand un journaliste n'y
comprend rien il prend un type qui dit
blanc est un type qui dit noir et il se
dit que comme ça le lecteur y retrouvera
plus facilement ces petits que lui
évidemment que c'est faux alors la
raison pour laquelle on est dans cet
amphi en voici une première c'est que
cette petite boule bleue enfin à
l'échelle de cette planche qui nous
héberge et là une caractéristique c'est
qu'elle a un diamètre qui ne varie pas
au cours du temps d'accord il n'y a pas
de grands génies bienfaisant qui fait
qu'à mesure que la population humaine
augmente on donne un grand coup de pompe
à vélo dans la terre et la terre
augmente de taille
l'histoire de pouvoir accueillir de plus
en plus de monde donc on a une planète
qui il ya quelques siècles et même du
reste il ya quelques millions d'années
faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre et kiala très sale manie de ne
pas vouloir augmenter de taille au cours
du temps pendant que la population qui
habite dessus elle a un tout petit peu
augmenté au cours du temps
donc on a un problème de boîte de pétri
actuellement c'est sarah que je vais
vous évoquez vous savez la boîte de
pétri c'est le truc qu'on utilise dans
les expériences en biologie là on met
des bactéries dedans et puis la colonie
de bactéries se développent et puis
quand elle a plus rien à bouffer par l
valeur et ben on a exactement le même
problème sur terre on apprenne de boîtes
de pétri
c'est à dire qu on a une boîte d'une
taille donnée sur laquelle on a une
espèce qui a trop bien réussi
nous qui est en train d'exploser en
effectifs et les questions energy
ressources climat biodiversité etc
s'inscrivent toutes dans un déséquilibre
croissant qui existe entre la taille de
la boîte et le nombre de gens qui
la boîte vous avez ici l'évolution de
l'humanité depuis que nous nous sommes
sédentarisés c'est-à-dire il ya dix
mille ans on verra un peu plus tard
pourquoi on s'est sédentarisé il ya dix
mille ans et paille à 15000 et paille à
20000 et payet 3000 et au moment où
l'humanité se sédentarisent les agents
du recensement de l'époque nous disent
que nous sommes quelques millions sur
terre ils ont très soigneusement
travaillé je vous rassure donc à ce
moment là il ya quelques millions de
bipèdes sur la planète
andy milan malgré les famines la peste
etc et les coronavirus de l'époque
nous avons quand même des effectifs qui
augmentent d'un facteur 100 en gros et
au début de la révolution industrielle
nous sommes quelques centaines de
millions et puis là en l'espace de huit
générations c'est pas beaucoup une
génération un à l'échelle d'une espèce
qui en a connu des milliers eh bien nous
passons à 8 à peu près milliards
d'individus
et c'est évidemment cette affaire-là qui
est un des déterminants du problème que
nous allons évoquer maintenant alors je
vous avais dit que je parlerai d'énergie
c'est effectivement ce que je vais faire
mais je vous encore une fois ça
s'inscrit dans ce que je viens de dire
on va parler d'énergie
vous savez qu'il ya un ministre de
l'énergie depuis que je suis petit
depuis que j'ai l'âge de raison il ya un
ministre qui est chargé de l'énergie
alors je vous fiche mon billet que la
quasi totalité des ministres de
l'énergie qu'on a eue si on leur avait
posé la question ça veut dire quoi ce
cadre votre titre il n'aurait pas été
foutu de donner la bonne réponse
il vous en aurez donné plein mais
sûrement pas la bonne quand on dit
énergie il ya un certain nombre de
réflexes pavloviens qui viennent en
général à l'esprit des gens que je vais
détailler aujourd'hui avant quand même
de vous donner la bonne réponse
le premier réflexe pavlovien c'est celui
des gilet jaune
l'énergie est une facture donc vous
dites énergie quelque part dans un
débarras et l'association de
consommateurs ou sautent sur le poêle en
vous disant il faut que l'énergie coûte
pas cher donc en gros l'énergie c'est
une facture non j'ai posé une petite
question dans l'amphi
qui ici est locataire bon ça fait du
bien d'aller chez les pauvres parce que
quand on parle des chefs d'entreprises y
en a pas un donc la question qui suit ça
marche pas dont vous êtes locataire a
longtemps les gens ici qui sont
locataires qui n'a aucune idée de
l'ordre de grandeur de son envoyé dans
les gens qui sont ici locataires qui
paye une facture d'électricité alors ou
même qui ici connaît à la dizaine
d'euros près le montant de sa dernière
facture
allez on va dire un tiers des mains qui
se sont levés juste avant le petit
expérience que je viens de la petite
expérience que je viens de faire à
l'instant vous dit que tout le monde
connaît sa facture de loyer absolument
tout le monde pas une main qui s'est pas
levé sur la facture de loyer alors que
vous avez une partie non négligeable des
gens qui sont locataires qui n'ont pas
une idée très exacte de leur facture
d'électricité et il ya une raison très
simple à ça c'est que les factures
d'énergie sont en général des petites
factures
sauf si vous êtes un fondeurs
d'aluminium ou quelqu'un qui produit du
nickel ou etc donc si vous êtes dans des
endroits qui sont extrêmement
électro-intensifs la facture
d'électricité est une petite facture
prenez même la sncf qui est le premier
consommateur d'électricité de france la
sncf est le premier utilisateur
industriels et même tout court
d'électricité en france
par ailleurs la sncf est également un
des premiers consommateurs de carburants
en france puisque tous les ter qui
fonctionnent au diesel achètent des
carburants est bien la moule montant des
achats d'énergie à la sncf c'est 3 % des
charges
si vous virer 3 % des charges de la sncf
sous forme de cheminots vous avez une
grève dure longtemps mais ça finit par
repartir si vous virer 3 % des charges à
la sncf sous forme d'électricité de
carburant et plus de sncf c'est ce qu'a
pu un train qui avancent donc c'est une
c'est indispensable mais pourtant c'est
une toute petite facture et donc si vous
raisonnez économie ce qu'on a souvent
tendance à faire dans les cours
d'économie
de voir l'énergie comme une commodité
qu'on achète à ce moment vous allez
passer à côté de l'essentiel du problème
vous allez vous dire bon ses loisirs
j'y consacre quelques pour cent du temps
et le reste du temps je m'occupe de
trucs sérieux et soit dit en passant
dans les entreprises c'est en général
comme ça que ça se passe en général
l'énergie étant une petite facture il ya
un type en haut niveau et de -3 sauf
quand vous êtes dans une entreprise
extrêmement énergie intensive
vous avez un type dans un coin dans le
haut niveau à au moins trois qui
s'occupe du problème et surtout qu'ils
viennent pas nous enquiquiner parce
qu'on s'occupe de choses sérieuses des
produits qu'on vend des salaires etc
l'énergie c'est un petit machin dans un
coin alors sur un raisonnement il est
aussi opérant que si je vous disais
votre cervelle ces 2 % de votre masse et
donc vous pas la peine de vous en
occuper plus de 2 % du temps le reste du
temps vous pouvez vous occuper d'autre
chose occupez vous donc de vos muscles
qui pèse beaucoup plus lourd et de vos
os qui pèse beaucoup plus lourd
donc quand vous avez un raisonnement
économique sur l'énergie en fait vous
allez rater l'essentiel qui est que la
totalité du monde moderne dépend de
l'énergie que ça nous coûte de 3,5 en
tout 90 % de ce qu'on paye c'est juste
pas le sujet ce qui va compter
et que je vais vous montrer maintenant
c'est que tout le reste en dépend le
deuxième réflexe pavlovien que vous avez
probablement tous entendu la meilleure
énergie est celle qu'on n'utilise pas
raté la meilleure énergie est celle
qu'on utilise c'est bien pour ça que
depuis le début de l'histoire des hommes
voilà à quoi ressemble l'évolution de
l'utilisation d'énergie sur terre on en
utilise de plus en plus et je vais vous
montrer dans pas très longtemps que si
on utilisait pas d'énergie si des hommes
n'avaient pas utilisé de plus en plus
d'énergie jamais vous auriez eu le temps
de faire les études que vous faites vous
seriez occupés alors comme on est près
de la mer à aller pêcher des poissons ou
éventuellement à ramasser des patates
voilà vous seriez occupé à ça seriez
vous auriez absolument pas le temps
c'est ce que je vais vous expliquer
derrière de faire des études et d'aller
au cinéma le soir
donc si vous avez le temps aujourd'hui
de faire ça c'est justement parce qu'on
n'a pas économisé d'énergie troisième
réflexe pavlovien que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est il faut que ce soit
100% vénère aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un
acteur
dans le domaine de la transition
énergétique qui ne vous disent pas on va
faire 100% renouvelable premier ministre
venu vous dit ça le premier chef
d'entreprise venus vous dis ça et ces
questions pourquoi pourquoi à ce moment
ci les renouvelables c'est si
merveilleux ça fait des siècles que nous
passons notre temps à faire l'exact
inverse de ce qu'il faudrait faire
voilà un bateau il ya deux siècles il
est 100% renouvelable
il est fait en bois renouvelables il
navigue sur la mer renouvelables il a
des voiles en coton et en lin
renouvelables monte sur des mâts
renouvelables avec des cordes en chanvre
renouvelables alors on triche déjà de ce
bateau il ya quelques férus en acier par
nos enfants en faire pas renouvelable et
peu importe et avec des marins
renouvelables qui parfois attrape le
scorbut renouvelables donc ce bateau il
ya deux siècles
nous l'avons remplacée par des bateaux
fossiles qu'on a trouvé achement mieux
comme dirait l'autre puisque si c'était
pas achement mieux on n'aurait pas fait
d'accord donc on a remplacé le bateau
renouvelable par un bateau pas
renouvelable voici des transports
terrestres il ya deux siècles ou trois
siècles parfaitement renouvelables alors
de nouveau un cheval renouvelables à un
conducteur renouvelables du alors la
route de nouveaux route riches parce que
les roues sont cerclés avec du fer pas
renouvelable mais bon l'essentiel et
renouvelables ils mangent de l'herbe
renouvelables et on a remplacé sa part
un camion pas renouvelable en se disant
quand même c'était beaucoup plus
efficace voici un tracteur renouvelables
des temps anciens qui mangent de l'herbe
renouvelables tirant une charrue en bois
renouvelables etc et on a remplacé sa
pas un tracteur moderne parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on peut avoir un hamburger
d'une marque que je ne nommerai pas pour
pas cher
voici des travaux publics renouvelables
grâce auquel on n'aurait jamais pu
satisfaire les promesses électorales de
rajouter un rond point en six mois et
grâce à ça maintenant on peut le faire
voici les travaux publics des temps
modernes parfaitement pas renouvelable
mais grâce auquel ça va un peu plus vite
de faire l'équivalent des voies romaines
qui elles nécessitaient les ouvriers
renouvelables dans voici de la
construction renouvelable
qui était celle que nous avions il ya
quelques siècles avec des ouvriers
mangeant de la nourriture renouvelables
utilisant du bois des pierres par
renouvelables enfin il y en avait quand
même beaucoup
et voici ce qui permet de faire
aujourd'hui des grands cornichons à la
défense en six mois
enfin en un an avec une finition c'est à
dire une construction parfaitement faux
cils avec des cimenteries fossiles des
aciéries fossiles et des grues fossiles
enfin tout ça est fait avec de l'énergie
fossile et fonctionnant à l'électricité
pas très facile en france mais fossiles
dans le monde
voici une industrie renouvelables
utilisant un moulin à eau renouvelable
et on s'est dit que quand même pour
remplir les supermarchés ça marche est
vachement mieux d'avoir une industrie
fossile donc on a fossilisés l'industrie
et voici un séchoir à récolte
renouvelables qui s'appelle le soleil et
voici un séchoir moderne à luzerne qui
fonctionnent au gaz
donc ça fait deux siècles que nous
passons notre temps à faire l'exact
inverse du slogan très à la mode
aujourd'hui qui est que nous allons
avoir une énergie 100 % renouvelable
question est ce que c'est parce que nos
ancêtres étaient des crétins patenté
malfaisants ou est ce qu'il ya une vraie
raison physique à ce que nous ayons
suivi cette évolution est la réponse est
malheureusement que si on a fait ça
c'est parce qu'il ya une raison physique
à ce qu'on ait suivi cette évolution
parce que les combustibles fossiles nous
permettent d'avoir une source d'énergie
disponible à volonté
pilotable facilement transportable
facilement stockables et permettant
d'avoir des grandes puissances
ce que les énergies diffusé
intermittente ne nous permettent pas
d'avoir ou en tout cas pas facilement le
vent est connu depuis des milliers
d'années les moulins à vent existe
depuis des milliers d'années donc si
l'éolien par exemple était
intrinsèquement supérieur aux énergies
fossiles pas cher etc
question pourquoi est ce qu'on serait
emmerder à passer au pétrole plutôt que
de rester au vent si le vent est
intrinsèquement supérieur a aucune
raison de le faire
lorsque je vais vous montrer maintenant
c'est que il n'est pas intrinsèquement
supérieur justement c'est bien simple
problème imaginons qu'on prenne un cube
d'air qui est en gros le volume de cette
pièce encore un cube d'air de 10 mètres
de côté et un ordre de grandeur ses
volumes de cette pièce imaginons que je
le fasse souffler alors un peu moins
vite que dans la tempête klaus mais un
peu plus vite que dans le calme plat
c'est à dire 45 80 km/heure et imaginons
que je fasse passer souvent à travers
une éolienne pardon je vais donc
récupérer de l'énergie électrique
faisant passer souvent eh bien tout
l'air de cette pièce passant à travers
une éolienne à 80 km/heure
ça vous permet de récupérer à l'arrivée
la même quantité d'énergie que celle que
vous avez dans la combustion de 3000
litres de pétrole question à votre avis
est-ce que c'est plus simple de partir
avec sous le bras
mille mètres cubes d'air ou avec sous le
bras 3000 litres de pétrole est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est plus simple
d'utiliser quand on en a envie 3000
litres de pétrole ou quand on en a envie
l'air de cette pièce en mouvement
vous avez la réponse
c'est évident que c'est considérablement
plus simple tant qu'il ya du pétrole et
que enfin et que tank et du pétrole en
fait d'aller faire un trou dans la terre
pour le sortir plus tôt que de
s'emmerder à attendre que le vent
souffle en bâtissant des collecteurs de
très grande taille pour essayer d'en
récupérer une partie et c'est bien pour
ça qu'on est passé des moulins à vent au
pétrole
si on parle argent soit dit en passant
est alors même que l'éolienne est
construite avec des moyens modernes
alors même que l'éolienne est construite
en bénéficiant du fait que toute
l'industrie fonctionne au pétrole ou au
charbon et au gaz
alors même qu'on a ça l'éolien vous
donne un kilowattheure à quelques
centimes alors là j'avais mis six à huit
ça on peut longuement discuté ça peut
être quatre à six peu importe alors que
le kilowattheure de pétrole sorti depuis
ivo une fraction de centimes même encore
aujourd'hui
donc vous avez un rapport surtout si
vous rajoutez la fonction de stocks que
vous devez mettre derrière votre
éolienne
vous avez un rapport 50 à 100 sur le
prix c'est à dire sur la quantité de
travail humain nécessaire
pour sortir un kilowattheure de
l'environnement quand vous passez du
vent au pétrole
vous allez gagner un facteur de quelques
cents de quelques dizaines à une
centaine physiquement et c'est ça la
raison pour laquelle on a fait ce chemin
des énergies renouvelables vers les
énergies fossiles
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
donnent la part de chaque énergie
utilisée dans le monde depuis un siècle
et demi lorsque vous voyez sur ce
graphique c'est que la part des énergies
fossiles qui est représenté par ce trait
moutarde de la augmente continûment
pendant la révolution industrielle donc
en fait la révolution industrielle
consiste essentiellement à mettre au
travail des machines qui fonctionnent
aux énergies fossiles
c'est à ça que ça sert la révolution
industrielle et vous voyez que depuis
les chocs pétroliers c'est à dire les
années 70 bien cette part est à peu près
constante alors le programme nucléaire
l'a fait un tout petit peu baissé et
puis ça remonte un peu tout ça peut
enfin voila en gros
neil nucléaire ni les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables ne sont perceptibles dans
cette évolution
d'accord essentiellement le monde est
shootée aux énergies fossiles et c'est
exactement ça qu'on a fait depuis deux
siècles on sait shooter progressivement
aux énergies fossiles
la vraie question c'est pourquoi est ce
qu'on a fait ça est la bonne réponse
la voici donc donc en france est
compréhensible même par des lycéens
normalement c'est parce que grâce à ça
on est devenus superman est super woman
pour de break
on va le dire en des termes un peu plus
sophistiquée à partir de maintenant mais
c'est exactement ça que la croissance de
l'approvisionnement énergétique nous a
permis de faire
on est devenus superman est super
roumagne pour de vrai alors pour
expliquer pourquoi c'est ça la bonne
conclusion on va revenir à un peu de
physique
tous les étudiants dans cette salle
savent normalement maintenant ou en tout
cas ils sont capables de comprendre que
l'énergie avant d'être un sujet de débat
citoyen ou pas citoyen avant d'être un
objet de promesses politiques
c'est une grandeur physique l'énergie
est une grandeur physique normative
quantifiable d'accord il ya des jours
pour compter l'énergie
et ma définition parce qu'il y avait
plusieurs définition normative mais ma
définition de l'énergie c'est l'énergie
c'est ce qui permet de quantifier le
changement d'état d'un système c'est ça
la définition de l'énergie cse qui
quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système je vais vous le dire maintenant
on des termes un tout petit peu plus
plus en langage courant
j'ai envie de dire l'énergie cse qui
quantifie la transformation du monde
donc dès que vous avez quelque chose
autour de vous qui se transforme une
vitesse une masse une une température
etc
le l'état dans l'état d'un d'un corps
dans un champ avec lequel il interagit
etc vous avez de l'énergie qui entend je
vous n'avez pas la possibilité de
transformer le monde qui vous entoure
sans énergie vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de mettre en jeu de
l'énergie sans que quelque chose se
transforme dans le monde qui nous
entoure et plus on utilise d'énergie
plus on transforme et donc plus on a les
effets bénéfiques de cette
transformation mais plus on a aussi des
effets indésirables de cette
transformation on aura toujours les deux
sens comme toutes grandeurs physiques le
l'énergie est soumise à des lois qui ne
dépendent pas de nous donc il ya quand
même depuis que je m'intéresse au sujet
chaque année consciencieusement des
responsables politiques qui pensent
qu'on va réussir violé les lois de la
physique par un vote à l'assemblée
nationale quand vous regardez bien une
partie de ce qui est sous jacent dans
les programmes politiques ça revient à
ceyrat ça revient à penser que la
volonté populaire va comment dire forcer
les lois de la physique a changé
quelques doutes et dans les lois de la
physique qui sont pas viables
il y en a une que vous connaissez par
coeur évidemment cette salle qui est la
loi de conservation
l'application de la loi de conservation
à la l'humanité a une conséquence très
simple c'est que pour les hommes
utiliser de l'énergie veut
nécessairement dire aller la chercher
dans l'environnement là où elles
existent déjà
les hommes ne peuvent pas créer de
l'énergie en leur sein à partir de rien
harry potter y arrive avec sa grosse
baguette de sureau
non si donc voila et merlin l'enchanteur
aussi pas très loin d'ici enfin suis un
peu plus au nord quand même y arrive
aussi mais vous non donc vous comme moi
comme tous les hommes
tout ce qu'on est capable de faire en
matière d'énergie c'est d'aller la
chercher dans l'environnement là où
elles existent déjà et de l'utiliser à
notre profit et l'utiliser à notre
profit ça veut dire la faire passer dans
ce qu'on appelle un convertisseur
c'était quelque chose qui va être
capable de récupérer cette énergie est
d'en faire autre chose le premier
convertisseur que mère nature où dieu ça
dépend de vos croyances nous est donné
c'est nous mêmes nous sommes un
convertisseur d'énergie
on a la capacité d'aller chercher dans
l'environnement deux types d'énergie la
chaleur du soleil en direct et de la
nourriture et nous allons en faire de la
chaleur beaucoup pour qu'on se
maintienne à 37 degrés du travail un peu
quand vous avez un animal à sang froid
qui lui est capable de se chauffer
essentiellement avec la chaleur du
soleil et qu'il n'a pas besoin de son
métabolisme à terme pour ça et bien en
gros ils mangent dix fois moins à
activité identique par rapport à un
animal à sang chaud
et puis comme les hommes sont poussés
par un désir d'accumulation sans limite
qui remonte aux temps préhistoriques
donc on mange autant qu'on peut on
on se reproduit autant qu'on peut on
s'informe autant qu'on peut et c'est à
un moment on se dit que l'on doit
pouvoir faire mieux et qu'on doit
pouvoir mobiliser à notre profit
d'autres convertisseur biologique c'est
la domestication des animaux et
l'esclavagé donc l'esclavagé la
domestication des animaux c'est je vais
chercher d'autres convertisseur
biologique dans la nature et je les
exploitent à mon profit comme ça
j'augmente ma capacité d'action sur
l'environnement
le temps passe et on se dit qu'on peut
exploiter des convertisseurs inanimé non
biologique qui utilisent des énergies
renouvelables l'apparition des boulin
notamment et de la marine à voile
et puis le temps passe encore et à ce
moment il ya watts papin et leurs petits
copains qui découvre quelque chose de
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on avait avant
et ils découvrent les machines qui sont
faites en métal c'est à dire les mâles
et les machines à vapeur et les moteurs
à combustion interne et qui sont
capables d'exploiter encore une nouvelle
source d'énergie que nous mêmes nous ne
sommes pas capables d'exploiter en
direct
donc quand on vous dit que vous
consommez de l'électricité en fait vous
mettez pas les doigts dans la prise
enfin je vous le déconseille c'est pas
ça que vous fait consommer de
l'électricité en fait s'est mobilisée à
votre profit un convertisseur qui lui
utilise de l'électricité
c'est ça que ça veut dire de même que
vous ne consommez pas du pétrole on
s'est tu préfères c'est beaucoup mieux
d'aller dans un restaurant mais mauvais
que de boire du pétrole donc à partir de
maintenant quand vous entendez énergie
il faut que vous barrier le mot énergie
et que vous le remplacez par le bo
machine du convertisseur c'est un peu
brutal comme expression ce pas un truc
qu'on aime beaucoup utilisé de plus en
plus d'énergie c'est donc tout
simplement mobilisés de plus en plus de
machines c'est à dire de plus en plus de
prothèses qui augmente les capacités de
notre corps c'est exactement ça a
utilisé plus en plus d'énergie c'est se
greffer un nombre croissant de prothèses
qui augmente les capacités de notre
corps et qui nous transforment
effectivement en superman est super
woman pour de vrai c'est ça utiliser de
plus en plus d'énergie
petit ordre de grandeur pour vous
montrer de quoi on parle maintenant
quand on utilise une machine je vais
imaginer que nous partons loin de nantes
qui n'est pas connu pour ses massifs
montagneux élevé et que nous allions
faire soit un peu d'alpinisme soit
grimper sur un édifice un peu haut
alors quand je suis à paris je parle de
la tour eiffel restons parisien et on va
parler de la tour eiffel
donc on va imaginer que sinon vous
prenez le plus haut bâtiment nantais
vous faites la conversion la règle de
trois jeunes qui arrivera sur donc on va
imaginer que avant le petit déjeuner
pour vous mettre en forme vous alliez
faire 2000 mètres de dénivelé avec un
petit sac à dos sur le dos d'accord lors
de 1000 mètres de dénivelé pour ceux
d'entre vous qui y voit à peu près ce
qu'est paris ça fait six points cinq
fois l'ascension de la tour eiffel à
pied précise pas dans l'ascenseur à
touristes pour ceux d'entre vous qui
font un peu d'alpinisme 2000 mètres de
dénivelé c'est la moitié de ce qui
sépare chamonix du sommet du mont blanc
et là c'est pareil vous n'avez pas le
droit de monter dans le train à
crémaillère ainsi à pinces donc
imaginons vous fassiez de 1000 mètres de
dénivelé ce qu'une personne bien
entraînées et capables de faire
raisonnablement dans une journée et bien
à ce moment vous aurez fournit de
l'énergie avec vos jambes et cette
énergie c'est raïs et votre masse contre
le champ gravitationnel c'est ça donc
l'énergie que vous fournissez est très
simple à calculer fgh mais moi j'y
arrive encore
et si vous faites ce petit calcul avec
un corps qui fait 90 kg tout mouillé
donc 80 + 10 parce que comme ça c'est
simple vous arrivez à 1,8 mégajoule
c'est à dire très exactement à 2 bis
kilowattheure donc une personne qui
travaille avec ses jambes toute la
journée
alors là c'est la version ascension pour
pédaler sur un vélo aussi un pareil à la
fin de la journée
ses jambes ont réussi à restituer une
énergie mécanique qui est un ridicule
demi kilowattheure ce que vous allez
voir après que face à l'énergie
mobilisée par les machines totalement
ridicule
si vous faites ça un jour sur deux ce
qui revient à dire que vous faites 3
fois la tour eiffel tous les matins
avant d'aller travailler
à la fin de l'année vous aurez fournit
une énergie mécanique de 100 kilowatts
heure alors vous faire ça un jour sur
deux sait faire une étape du gr20 tous
les jours voilà du 1er janvier au 31
décembre sans les blagues vaseuses de
paul board
donc à la fin de l'année vous aurez fait
100 kilowatts heures vous aurez fournit
100 kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
si maintenant vous êtes ouvriers dans
les travaux publics et que vous faites
un grand trou pour faire passer le
tramway nantais et que vous des quais
ses six mètres cubes de terre dans la
journée pour le remonter de 1 m donc
j'ai toujours eu et galen g h1 que j'ai
pris et bien vous êtes dix fois plus
ridicule que mon alpinistes malgré les
15 tonnes de terre que vous aurez ici
d'un mètre dans la journée puisque en
ait un effort de cette nature sur une
journée c'est 0,05 kilowattheure c'est
vraiment pas beaucoup et si vous faites
ça un jour sur deux toute l'année vous
aurez mal au dos et des ampoules et vous
aurez fourni 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique dans l'année donc un
homme au travail de force ou une femme
au travail de force peut fournir dans
l'année quelque chose qui se balade
entre 10 et 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique
prenons maintenant un litre d'essence
objet de tous les émois dernièrement à
cause de son prix scandaleusement élevé
est d'accord avec moi c'est
scandaleusement élevés prix de l'essence
est bien dans un litre d'essence au prix
scandaleusement élevés vous avez dit
kilowattheures d'énergie thermique
quand ça brûle alors évidemment à cause
de carnot et des ingénieurs incapable on
n'arrive pas à en tirer 100 % d'énergie
mécanique on n'y arrive pas mais on
arrive quand même à en tirer 2 à 4
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique de
ce litre d'essence qui brûle c'est à
dire que dans 1 litre d'essence qui
brûlent qui scandalise manche eure
vous avez la même capacité à transformer
l'environnement que dans 10 à 100 jours
de travail de force d'un être humain
dont vous prenez 10 à 100 jours de
travail de force d'un être humain et
vous avez la combustion l'énergie
mécanique fournis par la combustion d'un
litre d'essence je vais vous le dire
encore autrement si je prends tous les
gens dans cette salle et que je vous
fais taper sur des cailloux pendant un
jour
d'accord on va tous au bar in là pour la
journée et bien à la fin de la journée
l'énergie mécanique que nous aurons
fournis se baladera quelque part entre
quelques litres et quelques dizaines de
litres d'essence
c'est à dire même pas un plein de
voitures pour la totalité de la salle
qui ferait qui cirait dubois qui
montrait des charges qui peut faire un
truc comme ça toute la journée qu'ils
dépasseraient de la terre qui voit là et
bien à la fin de la journée
quelques litres d'essence à quelques
dizaines de litres d'essence mis dans
une machine auront fait exactement
exactement la même transformation du
monde qui nous entoure
voilà ça vous donne une petite idée si
on raisonne argent on se rend compte que
l'argent ne réfléchis ne reflètent
pardon pas du tout cette cette affaire
là si je paye quelqu'un qui me
transforme le monde au smic selon qu'ils
utilisent ses bras ou ses jambes le
kilowattheure de transformation du monde
va me coûter de quelques centaines à
quelques milliers d'euros
pendant qu'en face la machine dans le
même service pour un coût marginal de
quelques dizaines de centimes c'est à
dire quelques centaines à quelques
milliers de fois moins voilà vous avez
ici l'origine de votre pouvoir d'achat
vous avez ici l'origine de la
tertiarisation des emplois vous avez ici
l'origine du développement de
l'industrie
vous avez ici d'origine de la
mondialisation vous avez ici l'origine
des études longues des retraites des
congés payés etc
tout tout tout relève de sa douce donc
c'est juste de la physique à la base
même la fin de l'esclavagisme en
occident relève de sens parce que
imaginons que vous preniez un esclave
alors pour tous ceux d'entre vous qui
ont vu django vous aurez remarqué que
esclaves en général c'est pas une
vocation de jeunesse vous n'êtes pas
très content d'être esclave que vous
n'avez qu'une seule envie c'est de
trucider votre patron et [ __ ] le camp
donc si vous avez un esclave vous allez
devoir l'empêcher de [ __ ] le camp
l'empêchait de vous trucider l'acheter
contre sa volonté de nourrir parce que
sinon perdez votre actif et si vous
mettez boutabout tous ses coups vous
vous rendez compte l'utiliser un esclave
ça vous coûte encore 10 à 100 fois plus
cher que la machine qui n'a strictement
rien contre sa condition de machines qui
travaillent h 24 qui ne se met pas en
grève et qui ne part pas en vacances et
qui n'a pas besoin d'être nourri
autrement que par du pétrole qui me
poussait en rien à vous puisque vous et
vous est pas le boire donc la raison
pour laquelle l'esclavagisme a disparu
en occident c'est pas parce que tout
d'un coup nous sommes devenus bon
d'accord tout d'un coup tous les
occidentaux ont lu rousseau il soutient
enfin des esclaves a pas du tout on
n'est ni pire ni meilleur que nos
ancêtres ya deux siècles on est
exactement les mêmes avec le même code
génétique n'en déplaise à laurent
alexandre
par contre nous n'avons strictement
aucune raison de recourir à quelque
chose qui est considérablement moins
efficace que la machine qui au surplus
jusqu'à une époque récente parce que
c'est en train de changer un peu été vu
comme quelque chose de parfaitement
moral est positif donc on n'a aucune
raison de ne pas le faire et c'est ça
qu'on fait donc recourir à l'énergie
c'est recourir aux machines et c'est
recourir à des à des entités qui ont une
capacité de transformation du monde
considérablement supérieure à la nôtre
avec le petit calcul que je viens de
faire donc un demi à un kilowatt heure
sur une journée vous auriez qu'on vous
aurez compris que ça veut dire que la
puissance moyenne de nos bras et de nos
jambes en actions se baladent quelque
part entre 10 et 100 watts corps
puissance moyenne de nos bras en action
s'est dit what pas beaucoup d'iwata
ravale un peu de fierté et la puissance
moyenne de nos bras en de nogent dans
l'action c'est 100 watts alors
maintenant on va prendre quelques
machines de la vie courante on va en
prendre une première par exemple qui
dans cette salle a déjà mixé de la soupe
c'est bien vous apprendrez aux autres
quand vous avez un mixeur à soupe dans
la main vous avez une machine d'accord
qui va vous fournir une énergie
mécanique qui va savamment vous broyer
ce que vous avez mis dans la soupe
délicieuse
est-ce que vous avez une idée de la
puissance moyenne d'un mixeur à soupe
1000 watts 3 dis donc tu as les moyens
non 300 400 watts
ouais et 400 watts est déjà un bon mix
sera souple alors 400 watts
ces quatre cyclistes c'est pas le même
volume 1 le mixeur à soupe les gros
comme ça et vous avez là dedans quatre
cyclistes qui pédalent d'accord si vous
deviez mettre quatre vrais cyclistes là
dedans et les payer je ne serai pas
exactement le même prix que le service
que vous rend votre mixeur assaut qui a
déjà passé l'aspirateur c'est bien les
gens sont propres ce que vous avez une
idée de la puissance moyenne de votre
aspirateur
oui 1500 watts fait bien c'est un homme
qui a répondu je précise donc votre
aspirateur y [ __ ] comme qu'un cycliste
à nouveau c'est pas le même prix qui est
déjà monté dans un ascenseur pièce tous
les autres ne prennent que les escaliers
jeunes en europe
j'ai jamais pris un ascenseur
non que des menteurs ici est-ce que vous
avez une idée de la puissance moyenne
d'un moteur d'ascenseur non ces quelques
kilowatts
ouais c'est ça quelques kilowatts donc
quand vous appuyez sur le bouton de
l'ascenseur allez hop 50 cyclistes se
mettent en action
on est content cinquante cyclistes se
mettre en action
voilà on pourrait continuer qui est déjà
monté dans un tracteur a pas mal et bien
quand vous montez dans le tracteur ces
quelques centaines de paires de jambes
qui se mettent en action où quelques
dizaines de chevaux
c'est à dire que si le tracteur devait
être remplacé par un dispositif
attelé ce qui soit dit en passant était
les premiers engins de labourage et même
de récolter les premières moissonneuses
batteuses apparaissent aux états unis au
début du 20e siècle et elles sont tirées
par des dizaines de chevaux et bien le
tracteur lui il remplace 50 60 70
quand vous êtes un gros céréaliers dans
la beauce même plus que ça encore
chevaux ou quelques centaines de paires
de jambes et vous allez voir dans pas
longtemps que la raison pour laquelle on
a vidé les campagnes dans tous les pays
occidentaux
c'est parce qu'on a remplacé les paires
de jambes par des tracteurs donc on n'a
plus besoin des paires de jambes
un engin de travaux publics les ronds
points les fameux rond-point lui il vous
développe la même puissance que quelques
milliers de paires de bras d'accord donc
vous avez un tractopelle comme ça une
grue etc
allez hop vous avez plus besoin de
quelques milliers d'ouvriers avec des
pelles et des pioches
vous pouvez tous les envoyer voir
ailleurs et voulait remplacer par un
engin comme ça
le camion dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
la qui a remplacé mais charrette à bras
lui il [ __ ] comme quelques milliers de
fois les jambes du conducteur
quand vous avez un laminoir alors j'ai
pas vu d'avion l'avion il a la même
puissance que le train il est en gros 20
fois plus puissant que le camion 20 à 30
fois plus puissant est ce pour ça que
les conducteurs de train sont mieux
payés que les conducteurs de camions et
l'avion lui il a une puissance qui est à
peu près celle d'un laminoir industriel
c'est pour ça que les pilotes d'avion
sont mieux payés que les conducteurs de
train et puis comme il [ __ ] plus fort
ils sont jeunes et svelte et en forme et
vous avez ici donc là un laminoir
industriel un laminoir industriels comme
vous avez par exemple à dunkerque ou à
fos-sur-mer et bien quand l'ouvrier qui
pilote le laminoir à rentrer dans la
cabine de pilotage
il voit instantanément la puissance de
ses bras x 10 millions superman pour de
vrai alors c'est pas le costume de
superman avec un bourez dessus ou le
costume d'iron man qui fait que la
claque avec la lumière
mais c'est pareil il rentre il se donne
une prothèse qui démultiplient sa force
par 10 millions voilà c'est ça l'ouvrier
qui rentre dans la cabine d'un laminoir
si on devait supprimer le laminoir de
fos sur mer et le remplacer par des
êtres humains
tapant avec des marteaux sur des tôles
et ben vous voyez je prends plus que la
totalité de la population étudiante en
france et elle ne sert plus qu'à une
chose c'est à taper sur des tôles toute
la journée donc lui il se marre là la
raison pour laquelle vous avez le droit
de suivre des études
c'est à cause de ça c'est parce que les
machines travail à votre place si les
machines étaient pas là pour travailler
à votre place vous auriez pas du tout le
temps de faire des études
on aime ça les machines on les aime
beaucoup alors on les aime tellement que
le temps passant on en a mis de plus en
plus à la de service vous avez ici la
quantité de nourriture pour machines
je dis bien la quantité de nourriture
pour machines utilisées par terriens
depuis un siècle et demi donc vous
prenez un homme ou une femme et vous
regarde et non pas la quantité d'énergie
qui l'utilisent puisque je viens de vous
dire que c'est pas l'homme et la femme
qui utilisent de l'énergie sauf ce qu'on
mange et la chaleur du soleil quand on
dit qu'on utilise l'énergie en fait ça
veut dire qu'on donne à manger à des
machines donc ici vous avez la quantité
de croquettes pour machines que nous
avons utilisés au cours du temps encore
c'est ça que vous avez sur ce graphique
ce que vous voyez c'est que il ya un
siècle et demi les croquettes pour
machines sont essentiellement constitués
de bois
donc on faisait des palettes n'en fait
pas des palettes à l'époque
essentiellement constitués de bois et
les machines à qui on donne à manger
avec ce bois c'est des forges
c'est des poils pour se chauffer c'est
les premières machines à vapeur
voilà c'est ça les salles et des
cheminées en faveur avec le temps par
personne on utilise de moins en moins de
machines qui mangent du bois par contre
on va utiliser de plus en plus de
machines qui mangent du charbon est ce
que vous voyez sur ce graphique c'est
que la quantité de charbon utilisé ou
plus exactement mobilisés par therrien
n'a jamais cessé d'augmenter depuis que
les hommes ont commencé à utiliser du
charbon donc le charbon n'a jamais été
une énergie du passé
jamais il ne s'est produit depuis le
début de l'histoire du charbon dans
l'histoire des hommes
un moment où on en utilise est moins
qu'avant par personne non seulement on
en utilise est pas moins qu'avant tout
court mais on en utilise est même pas
moins qu'avant par personne
il a raison à cette augmentation forte
de la quantité de charbon utilisé c'est
que les deux tiers du charbon qu'on
extrait d'une mine dans le monde
finissent leur vie dans une centrale
électrique et inversement nous verrons
que le charbon est de très loin le
premier mode de production électrique
sur terre ce que vous voyez sur ce
graphique également c'est que les
diverses formes d'énergie mobilisés par
les hommes c'est d'ailleurs mobilisés
par les machines ne se substitue pas
quand on regarde en séries longues ailes
s'empilent les unes sur les autres
donc par dessus le charbon est pas du
tout en remplacement nous nous sommes
mis à utiliser des machines qui mangent
des croquettes au pétrole et ses
machines qui mangent des croquettes au
pétrole s'est essentiellement des
machines qui servent à déplacer des
personnes ou des marchandises 98 % de
ceux qui roulent vol où naviguent sur
terre utilisent du pétrole donc le
pétrole c'est par essence sans mauvais
jeu de mots l'énergie des échanges et
c'est l'énergie de la mondialisation
sans pétrole
vous oubliez la mondialisation la
mondialisation est apparu avec le
pétrole elle disparaîtra avec le pétrole
on a utilisé du gaz on a utilisé
d'hydroélectricité on a utilisé du
nucléaire ans comme moi j'aime beaucoup
le nucléaire gelé mis en veille a pas de
raison après tout je suis libre de mon
code couleur et vous avez tout en haut
mais pas de raison et vous avez tout en
haut
ce qui excite aujourd'hui
considérablement les journalistes les
politiques etc
c'est à dire les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables mais qui sont pour
l'essentiel des anciennes énergies
renouvelables que nous avons abandonné
c'est à dire le vent le soleil et
éventuellement le bois enfin le biogaz
la biomasse
vous voyez ici l'importance respective
que ça par rapport au reste le solaire
est bien représenté 1 sur ce graphique
ces petits machins jaune là qui est
totalement invisible entre les deux
c'est ce qu'ils récoltent aujourd'hui la
plus grande quantité de milliards ça
veut pas dire que c'est ce qui se
développe le plus vite et par ailleurs
c'est pas parce que vous avez une grosse
capacité installée que vous avez une
grosse production
si vous avez une grosse capacité
installée et que ça produit pas souvent
eh ben vous n'aurez pas une grosse
production derrière
mais comme les gens du solaire font bien
leur promo il nous donne toujours les
chiffres sur les capacités installées et
pas les chiffres sur la production
ils sont pas fous alors j'en profite
pour rappeler une chose au vu de ce
graphique vous inquiète
élève ingénieur j'ai un petit conseil à
vous donner toute votre vie durant
ne prenez jamais ce qui est écrit dans
le journal comme une source opposable je
répète ne prenez jamais ce qui est écrit
dans le journal comme une source
opposable une source opposable ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous pouvez faire
confiance à ce qui est écrit ne fait
jamais ça un journal a ses règles de
fonctionnement propres qui font que le
respect des faits n'est pas ce qui
arrive en premier dans les règles de
fonctionnement ce qui arrive en premier
dans les règles de fonctionnement c'est
de rester vivant et d'avoir le plus de
lecteurs possible et si ça vient
tamponner le fait qu' on restitue
incorrectement les faits on restituera
incorrectement les faits ça ne pose
aucun problème ça fait 25 ans que je
fréquente des journalistes connaît des
centaines c'est le système qui veut ça
c'est pas des individus c'est le système
qui veut ça
donc ne fait et en plus quand le sujet
est technique et que les gens
comprennent pas bien de bonne foi il ya
un milliard de conneries qui circulent
donc je le répète alors je vais vous le
dire autrement il n'y a pas le moindre
lien entre l'importance réelle des
processus dans le monde et la pagination
dans ce journal n'est pas le moindre
lien entre les deux d'accord
donc c'est pas parce que le journal vous
rebat les oreilles toute la journée d'un
truc que c'est la plus importante des
choses qui se passe en ce moment dans le
monde
il n'y a pas le moindre lien entre les
deux j'insiste vraiment là-dessus parce
que la quantité de bêtises que je vois
fait dans les entreprises sur la base
d'une confiance accordée à la presse
dans des domaines qu'on connaît pas et
extrêmement significative à vous me
direz derrière ça me donne du business
parce qu'ensuite on embauche des
consultants pour comprendre ce qui se
passe vraiment mais c'est me fait très
attention à ça toute votre vie durant et
ça n'est pas propre qu'à l'énergie
c'est vrai quel que soit le domaine
c'est vrai quel que soit le dos donc des
vous voyez un truc qui vous interpellent
dans le journal la seule chose à faire
c'est de remonter à l'information
primaire pour comprendre ce qui se passe
c'est ça qu'il faut faire
la réalité du monde et je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure sur un graphique
c'est qu'aujourd'hui 80% de des
croquettes pour machines c'est de
l'énergie fossile et c'était déjà le cas
il ya quarante ans ça n'a absolument pas
changé en quarante ans par contre ce qui
a changé en un siècle et demi c'est que
la quantité moyenne de croquettes pour
machines disponibles par personne sur
terre ces vingt mille kilowattheures par
an c'est à dire que le costume de
superman que nous nous sommes taillés
grâce à l'énergie et aux machines
il a permis en gros de démultiplier la
force musculaire de chaque terrien par
un facteur de sang c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'aujourd'hui chaque
terrien dispose d'un costume de superman
qui à démultiplier sa puissance
musculaire par un facteur de sang c'est
ça que l'énergie nous a permis d'avoir
donc vous voyez que sur terre
l'essentiel de cette énergie fossile
évidemment ça ne concerne pas la france
qui est un pays tout nucléaire chacun
c'est ça qui n'a jamais entendu que la
france était un pays tout nucléaire au
folie's et le même journal que moi voici
un graphique maintenant qu'ils vous
donnent les croquettes pour machines en
france en fonction de l'endroit où se
trouve la machine donc si la machine
sert à fabriquer un objet de moins en
moins au grand dam d'arnaud montebourg
et tous ceux qui sont succédé derrière
c'est dans la colonne industrie si la
machine sert à transporter des personnes
et des marchandises
beaucoup trop souvent au grand dam de
madame elisabeth bornes eh bien ça se
trouve dans la colonne transports si la
machine est sur un lieu où s'exerce une
activité professionnelle hors
fabrication d'objets à ce moment ça se
trouve dans tertiaire si la machine est
chez vous parce que vous avez 1
milliards de machines chez vous comme je
disais tout à l'heure les tourniquets
tafer la soupe
enfin la vinaigrette les aspirateurs etc
dd tout l'électroménager est bien la
machine se trouve là et enfin si la
machine et la filière agricole elle se
trouve dans agriculture dont vous avez
là les tracteurs et moissonneuses
batteuses et autres moteurs qui met les
trucs dans les silos ce que vous avez
également sur ce graphique si si c'est
une échelle qui vous donne les milliards
de kilowattheures consommés par les
machines
selon l'envoi ou la machine se trouve et
le code couleur vous donne l'énergie
extraite de l'environnement ce qu'on
appelle l'énergie primaire qui a servi à
alimenter la machine
c'est ça que maintenant je vais cercle
et sur ce graphique tout ce qui provient
des combustibles fossiles en france et
je vous pose la question pensez vous que
la france soit un pays tout nucléaire
je pense que à tout le moins ça se
discute
à tout le moins ça se discute
l'électricité d'origine nucléaire en
france représente 2,5 fois moins
d'énergie que ce qui alimente les
machines et qui vient du pétrole en
france
donc la france est comme les autres pays
du monde occidental
un pays qui est essentiellement
dépendantes des énergies fossiles
ça n'empêche pas le gouvernement de
s'occuper essentiellement d'électricité
nucléaire en pensant que le truc le plus
urgent à faire c'est d'en utiliser un
peu moins ce qui de mon point de vue n'a
aucun intérêt sur aucun plan mais on y
avait un drap prêts et de se
contrefoutre comme de l'an 40 de ce qui
se passe en termes de combustibles
fossiles et soit dit en passant l'europe
est allemande
c'est exactement la même chose qui se
passe à l'europe dans la nouvelle
feuille de route de la commissaire
européenne à l'énergie le groupe pétrole
n'existe pas c'est la première énergie
consommée en europe c'est la moitié de
nos émissions de co2 le mot pétrole
n'est pas écrit dans la feuille de route
de la nouvelle commissaire européenne à
l'énergie race à ne pas pas nous
empêcher de faire à green deal le jeu
pourquoi
mais en attendant
c'est un green deal qui va s'occuper
essentiellement d'électricité le
responsable ou et qui va essentiellement
constituée à mon avis à faire ce qu'on
fait jusqu'à maintenant s'est rajouté
des éoliennes en disant que ça suffit à
régler le problème
non je reviens voyez par exemple qu'en
france l'essentiel du problème pétrolier
il est dans les transports donc il faut
avant tout un green deal c'est avant
tout un deal sur les transports dans ce
pays alors les voici les machines qui
mangent des croquettes pétrolières
gazières et charbonnières enfin voici
une petite partie en fait des machines
aujourd'hui il y en a des milliards et
elles ont tout fait dans l'univers qui
nous entoure
vous portez des vêtements qui ont été
faits par des machines des métiers à
tisser
dès que vous avez une fibre sur vous qui
est une fibre synthétique une fibre en
poly machin chouette là vous savez que
vous l'avez à 40 dans la machine
eh bien ça ça sort d'une plateforme
pétrolière vous avez mangé ce matin
grâce à des machines ce que vous avez
mangé ce matin si vous avez manger des
tartines ça a été fait avec du blé qui a
été semé avec des machines récolté avec
des machines fertiliser avec des
machines des usines d'engrais transporté
avec des machines des camions réduit en
poudre avec des machines un moulin etc
donc vous avez utilisé 1 milliards de
machines ce matin en mangeant et en vous
habillant personnes venues tout nu ici
vous êtes venus ici avec des machines
personne ici sauf ceux qui habitent sur
site n'est venu sans machine que ce soit
un vélo soit dit en passant une
trottinette le tram ou une voiture vous
et c'est donc vous nous sommes dans un
monde de machines et ces machines sont
nos esclaves des temps modernes mangeant
leur nourriture des temps modernes ayant
démultiplier notre puissance par
quelques centaines
ces machines ont donc permis de faire en
sorte que les hommes fassent de moins en
moins de travail physique même et
délègue ce travail physique de plus en
plus aux machines et ça a
fondamentalement changé la structure de
l'emploi
voilà la structure de l'emploi en france
sur deux siècles
il ya deux siècles nos lointains
ancêtres enfin moins lointain que ceux
qui couraient derrière les mammouths
sont essentiellement agriculteurs ça
veut dire que la majeure partie des gens
sont occupés à se nourrir eux mêmes
parce que c'est se nourrir est quand
même une des premières fonctions vitales
qu'on a l'obligation de faire de temps
en temps et comme il ya deux tiers de la
population qui est dans les champs ça
veut donc dire que chaque agriculteur il
est physiquement à même de se nourrir
lui même plus une demi personne qui fait
autre chose
c'est ça c'est ça la situation comme
avant une fois la première contrainte
c'est de se nourrir
ben vous avez autant de gens en dehors
de l'agriculture que vous avez de
surplus agricoles
c'est ça le sait ça le fonctionnement de
la société des temps anciens vous voyez
que la population agricole augmente de
1800 à 1850 alors à cette époque là la
quantité de nourriture qu'un agriculteur
est capable de fournir dans l'année donc
monde pas beaucoup par contre ce qui
augmente c'est la quantité de surface à
cultiver
parce que jusqu'en 1850 l'europe est
toujours en déforestation et nous
augmentons la quantité de surfaces
cultivables au détriment de la forêt en
1850 nous passons par le minimum
forestier à cette époque là la
couverture forestière en europe est
tombé à 15 %
aujourd'hui elle est remontée à 25 grâce
aux engrais et autres acteurs de la
couverture forestière est tombé à 15 %
et nous avons le maximum de surface
cultivable
après vous voyez que la quantité
d'agriculteurs va baisser parce que à
surfaces cultivables donné on est
capable d'augmenter la productivité
d'agriculteurs qu'est ce que ça veut
dire augmenter la productivité de
l'agriculteur ça veut pas dire qu'il lui
pousse des bras et des jambes
ça veut dire que vous allez mettre à son
service des machines dans un premier
temps ces machines ne sont pas
directement dans les champs elles sont
ailleurs que dans les champs c'est les
débuts de l'industrie et ses machines
vont fournir aux agriculteurs en
quantité croissante des colliers de
trait des charrettes des cerclages deux
roues des charrues et c'est donc des
choses qui sortent de l'industrie et qui
vont permettre à chaque agriculteur de
commencer à avoir un peu plus de
prothèse qu'il est capable de mettre au
bout de ses bras et de ses jambes et au
bout des animaux très
pour produire plus et puis après la
seconde guerre mondiale on va carrément
mettre les machines dans les champs ça
s'appelle détracteurs et on va également
mettre au service de l'agriculture des
machines surpuissantes qui s'appelle les
usines d'engrais et les usines de
phytosanitaires et à ce moment en 30 ans
entre 1945 et 1975
les rendements céréaliers en france sont
multipliées par sept à dix en 30 ans
grâce aux phytosanitaires aux engrais et
autres acteurs à nouveau à l'agriculteur
il lui a pas poussé pendant cette époque
des dizaines de paires de bras et de
jambes c'est pas ça qui s'est passé on
lui a juste donné des machines et
aujourd'hui vous avez 1 % de la
population française
non pas les deux tiers un pour cent de
la population française capable de
nourrir la totalité de la population
plus de créer des exportations et tout
ça s'est fait en plus en multipliant par
cinq la quantité de viande mangée par
personne et par an et quand vous mangez
de la viande vous avez besoin de plus de
culture à la bon que quand vous mangez
directement des végétaux je vais vous le
dire autrement la productivité et d'un
agriculteur a été multiplié par 100 à
200 sur cette période et le prix réel de
la nourriture a été divisée par
plusieurs dizaines aujourd'hui on se
plaint du prix de la nourriture jamais
quasiment dans l'histoire des hommes n 9
a lui aussi peu cher
donc attendez-vous à ce que ça remonte
dans les années et les décennies qui
viennent tout simplement parce que quand
tu auras moins d'énergie le prix de la
nourriture va augmenter c'est inexorable
pas ça veut pas se passer autrement il
ya un siècle la nourriture consommée 25
à 30 % du budget des ménages
il ya deux siècles c'était les deux
tiers aujourd'hui
si vous regardez le prix des aliments
par le prix du ticket de caisse en
sortie de carrefour dans lequel vous
avez le salaire de l'acacière ou du
caissier vous avez le salaire du
magasinier vous avez le budget
publicitaire de carrefour plus celui de
prendre annie plus les dividendes quand
il y en a des actionnaires de carrefour
plus la facture du transporteur plus est
c'est tout un tas de trucs qui n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec de la
nourriture
le ticket de la part de la nourriture
dans ticket de caisse aujourd'hui c'est
tout pour cent de ce que les gens
gagnent 2 %
ridicule
di cule c'est je le redis 10 x 10 à 15
fois moins qu'il ya un siècle pour une
quantité de viande qui a été multipliée
par cinq
donc le prix réel de la nourriture et en
particulier de la viande a été divisée
par plusieurs dizaines
merci d'énergie ça c'est grâce aux
croquettes pour machines nous avons de
plus en plus de croquettes pour machines
et donc on va les mettre en service ces
croquettes pour machines ailleurs que
dans les champs on va également les
mettre en service pour transformer
d'autres ressources que la photosynthèse
parce que dans les champs ce que vous
faites c'est que vous transformez la
photosynthèse
mais il ya des tas d'autres trucs il ya
les 92 éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
à sortir de partout alors on va s'y
coller on va mettre des mines absolument
partout sortir tout ce qu'on y trouve
et transformer tout ce qu'on y trouve
pour commencer à faire de plus en plus
d'objets ça s'appelle l'industrie qu'est
ce qu'un emploi dans l'industrie pour
ceux d'entre vous qui se souviennent des
temps modernes de chaplin c'est un
emploi de serviteurs de machines un
emploi dans l'industrie c'est un emploi
de serviteurs de machines lolë l'ouvrier
n'a aucune espèce d'utilité dans
l'industrie ici il n'ya pas de machine à
servir
je vous le dis autrement une industrie
sans machine est une industrie sans
emploi y a pas d'accord
sinon vous êtes cordonnier à la rigueur
et encore même le cordonnier il a besoin
de machine donc vous avez de plus en
plus de machines en fonctionnement
autour de nous et donc vous avez de plus
en plus d'emplois dans l'industrie après
les chocs pétroliers
la quantité d'énergie par personnes
s'arrêtent de croître en fête les chocs
pétroliers correspondent je vous montrer
un peu plus tard à une époque très
particulière dans l'histoire des hommes
ou la quantité d'énergie est à dire la
quantité de croquettes pour machines
disponibles par personne s'arrête de
croître mais à ce moment là on va
continuer quand même à faire augmenter
la taille des machines en robot 10 ans
et c'est donc on va pouvoir assurer une
production de plus en plus importante
avec de moins en moins de machines et
comme il ya de moins en moins de
machines parce qu'une ligne de
production robotisée
c'est une seule machine vous avez besoin
de moins en moins de gens la
désindustrialisation n'a pas du tout eu
lieu après les chocs pétroliers en
1974 et 2007 la production industrielle
française a doublé alors on a fait moins
de chaussettes plus de bateaux de
plaisance dans le coin et plus d'airbus
ailleurs la production industrielle a
augmenté juste c'est le fait de machines
de plus en plus grosse demandant de
moins en moins de monde donc l'emploi
dans l'industrie baisse les airbus à
nantes en plus voilà donc non seulement
ça navigue mais ça vole et comme il ya
de plus en plus d'objets mis en
circulation
il faut de plus en plus de gens pour
s'en occuper c'est les emplois de
service qu'est ce qu'on fait dans les
services on vend on finance on
entretient ont réparé ou pas cela
connaissances sur la manière de servir
des objets on enseigne et c'est donc
l'augmentation des services va de pair
avec l'augmentation de l'industrie est
ici vous voyez l'envolée des services
parce que le flux industriels continuent
à croître et ça c'est le résultat d'une
mécanisation abondante
je vais vous le prendre à l'envers
imaginons que demain matin vous n'ayez
plus d'industrie automobile en france
les gens à pau cilic me diront on en
prend le chemin d'un pas plus
d'industrie automobile enfants 20 plus
une voiture en france non pardon c'est
pas plus d'industrie c'est plus une
voiture vendue en france
à ce moment vous mettez au chômage tous
les gens qui financent des voitures
neuves dans les services vous mettez au
chômage tous les gens qui assurent des
voitures neuves dans les services vous
mettez au chômage tous les gens qui
répare les voitures note qu'ils sont
dans les services vous mettez
progressivement au chômage une partie
des gens qui s'occupent de réguler la
circulation parce qu'il ya de moins en
moins de circulation
vous remettez au chômage une partie
croissante des moniteurs d'auto école
puisqu'il n'y a plus besoin d'apprendre
à conduire des gens qui vont acheter des
voitures neuves
du coup vous mettez aussi une au point
un chômage une partie des gens qui font
les manuels pour les auto écoles etc
donc en fait vous mettez au chômage les
comptables qui s'occupait de compter
ceux qui afin de produire les chiffres
économiques de l'industrie automobile
mettez au chômage les consultant pour
l'industrie automobile
ça c'est plus gros bras de la faire et
c'est donc en gros et de fines temps qui
s'occupe de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
moins de voitures ce qui était également
un truc dramatique bon vous voyez que
tous ces gens qui sont dans les services
se retrouvent sans emploi
et je ne vous parle pas des
à feurs qui coiffe les ouvriers de
l'industrie automobile ce qui a plus
d'ouvriers dans l'industrie autorités
tardent donc vous voyez que vous avez
toute une frange des services qui
disparaît avec le flux industriels sous
jacent est en fait ce que je vais vous
montrer à partir de maintenant c'est que
contrairement à une idée couramment
répandue leur fraction de l'emploi dans
les services va de pair avec
l'automatisation du monde c'est à dire
la quantité de machines qui fonctionnent
dix autres avant une société fortement
tertiarisée est une société fortement
assise sur un parc de machines dans un
monde à l'énergie contrainte
vous ne serez pas dans un bureau à vous
casser le crâne pour savoir comment
optimiser une machine vous retournerez
ramasser des patates il n'y aa pas la
même fraction d'emplois dans les
services dans un monde à l'énergie
contrainte par ailleurs où s'exercent
les services l'industrie puis les
services dans les villes vous êtes
d'accord avec moi partir du moment où
vous chasser les agriculteurs des
campagnes parce que vous les remplacer
par des tracteurs et que par ailleurs
vous avez besoin de mettre tous les gens
au même endroit pour faire des voitures
et tous les gens au même endroit pour
faire des compagnies d'assurance pour
voiture parce que c'est comme ça que
c'est plus efficace à ce moment là vous
avez besoin de ville par ailleurs la
productivité agricole et l'apparition
des transports permet de nourrir des
gens même s'ils sont pas à côté des
champs temps vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
transport les gens ne peuvent pas être
nourri loin des champs à l'époque
ancienne à l'époque de lutèce est ce que
vous savez quelle était la taille le
nombre d'habitants à lutèce on va
commencer par une question plus facile
ce que vous savez quel est le nombre
d'habitants aujourd'hui dans
l'agglomération parisienne en ile de
france et 10 millions on peut se battre
toute la nuit pour savoir si on
considère que l'agglomération parisienne
c'est l'ile-de-france où c'est un peu
plus petit mais enfin ces quelques
millions est ce que vous savez quel
était le nombre d'habitants à lutèce la
fameuse lutèce de astérix le gaulois
qui était en fait astérix le breton oui
c'est sur un dix mille de cet ordre de
grandeur
pourquoi pourquoi il pas plus de dix
mille habitants à lutèce à l'époque
parce qu'à l'époque la première
contrainte des habitants de lutèce
c'était de manger et la taille d'une
ville était limitée par le surplus
agricoles dégagée par le disque
alentours que vous pouviez transporter
ce surplus agricoles en moins de temps
qu'il n'en fallait pour que les aliments
dépérissent c'est à dire quelques jours
ce que transporter de la farine sous la
flotte ou transporter j'ai pas quoi ou
des fruits en plein été à l'époque où
vous n'avez pas de moyens de
conservation vous avez quelques jours de
battement avant que tout pourri ce donc
lutèce avait une taille qui était
limitée par le surplus agricoles dégagé
par un disque qui était à quelques jours
de transport de charrette à bras
pour dire les choses simplement et si
vous faites un calcul d'ordre de
grandeur vous vous rendrez compte que
vous tombez sur une population
effectivement qui fait de l'ordre de
grandeur de la dizaine de milliers
d'habitants une fois que vous avez
l'énergie abondante et que vous pouvez
d'une part augmenter les surplus
agricoles c'est à dire que vous avez peu
de gens à nourrir dans les champs pour
beaucoup de nourriture exporté en dehors
des chants des moyens de transport
permettant de transporter cette
nourriture n'importe où faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui un camion sur trois en
france transportent un truc qui se mange
nous sommes totalement dépendants du
transport routier pour manger si demain
matin je supprime la totalité des
camions en france une partie des nantais
mourront de faim littéralement bouron de
faim d'accord c'est pas avec les jardins
urbains de nantes ce que vous aller
nourrir les nantais marchera pas pour
une horreur quelques abeilles mais vous
n'aurez pas les nantais avec ça donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes totalement
dépendants du transport routier pour
manger totalement donc le le fait que
l'on être les gens dans les villes je le
répète c'est le fait de l'énergie parce
que des surplus agricoles
le fait de l'énergie parce qu'à des
transports et le fait de l'énergie parce
que l'organisation optimale de la
production industrielle et des échanges
derrière
c'est à dire de l'activité tertiaire
c'est de mettre tout le monde au même
endroit et du reste vous remarquerez que
les villes anciennes ont toutes été
fabriquée de la même manière vous avez
au centre de la ville tout ce qui sert à
échanger quelque chose
la place de marché pour les objets
l'église pour les valeurs et la morale
l'école pour les savoirs la mairie la
préfecture la représentation de la
royauté whatever pour les règles de vie
en commun donc tout ce qui sert à
échanger quelque chose est au centre et
après on en passe les gens autour
en r + 3 ou r + 4 parce que c'est la
forme qui optimise les échanges il faut
avoir des villes qui sont apparues avec
la voiture comme aux états unis pour que
la notion de centre ville n'existe pas
donc si vous voulez faire rigoler un
américain vous allez atlanta vous lui
demandez où il centre ville et ils vous
regardent comme si vous parliez grecque
je comprends juste pas de quoi vous
parlez
et quand on a créé les transports
abondants on s'est permis d'avoir des
lieux des changes par exemple cet
endroit qu'il est plus en centre-ville
parce que l'énergie vous permet d'avoir
le flux des changes n'a pour tout
ailleurs après les chocs pétroliers vous
avez également une catégorie qui arrive
qui sont les gens dont on ne sait plus
quoi faire
c'est à dire que les chocs pétroliers
vont quand même limité suffisamment la
possibilité de donner des croquettes
pour machines un parc croissant de
machines pour que vous ayez assez
d'emplois et donc arrive une catégorie
de gens dont on ne sait plus quoi faire
parce qu'il n'y a plus assez de machines
pour mettre tout le monde au travail
c'est ça le chômage qui apparaît après
les chocs pétroliers
il apparaît partout dans le monde au
même moment donc c'est pas l'incurie des
politiques français qui fait qu'on a du
chômage après les chocs pétroliers
c'est structurel les étudiants dans
cette salle savent que quand vous faites
une expérience et que le résultat de
l'expérience est indépendant de la
valeur d'un paramètre c'est que ce
paramètre n'intervient pas dans le
résultat
le fait que le chômage et la dette
apparaissent dans tous les pays
occidentaux au même moment
indépendamment du fait que les pays se
soient revendique que les régimes
politiques ce soir revendiqué de gauche
de droite etc
c'est que en fait le déterminant
politique dans ce domaine là je vous le
montrer derrière est un déterminant du
troisième ordre et pas du tout un
déterminant capable d'agir à court terme
sur l'évolution du système
donc là vous avez l'évolution française
donc vous êtes je suis nous sommes le
résultat de l'abondance énergétique s'il
n'y avait pas l'abondance énergétique
nous serions là donc vous oubliez les
ingénieurs de centrale nantes ou
d'ailleurs vous oubliez le lycée tout le
monde est occupé à ramasser des patates
le pétrole le gaz le charbon et plus
marginalement le reste on fait que vous
avez un pouvoir d'achat a
considérablement supérieurs à ce qu'ils
étaient là même si on gueule pour les
retraites et pour le pouvoir d'achat
fait on se rend pas compte mais le
smicard français vit aujourd'hui comme
un nabab
c'est ça la vérité politique indicible
de cette affaire c'est que le smicard
français au regard de ce qui était les
conditions de vie d'un français du
moyen-âge vie comme un nabab et il est
pas content parce que bernard arnault
gagnent plus que lui mais objectivement
il vit comme un nabab et malheureusement
c'est l'autre vérité politique un décide
ça va pas durer
alors maintenant je reviens à mon
évolution
et je vais vous montrer quelques courbes
qui vous montre que c'est vraiment
structurelles vous avez ici un graphique
que j'ai fait il ya quelques années mais
aujourd'hui j'aurai le même résultat
dans lequel j'ai mis pour chaque pays
pour lequel j'avais les deux
informations en abscisse la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par personne et par
an dans ce pays
donc la quantité de croquettes pour
machines disponibles par personne et par
an et en ordonnée la part des gens qui
travaillent dans l'agriculture bien ce
que vous voyez de manière très nette
c'est que si je prends le monde
aujourd'hui un pays a d'autant moins de
sa population active dans l'agriculture
que il dispose de plus de croquettes
pour machines par personne tous les pays
qui ont eu de l'abondance énergétique à
cause de ce que je viens d'expliquer ont
donc évolué comme la france on a vidé
les campagnes et billie jean dans les
villes et comme par ailleurs dans les
villes on avait la possibilité de se
déplacer plus vite plus loin et pour
moins cher nous avons étalé les villes
ce processus est vrai dans tous les pays
du monde
seuls des contraintes géographiques ont
éventuellement pu l'en empêcher par
exemple en suisse où c'est pas facile
d'étaler les villes en allant bouffer
sur les flancs de montagne et bien les
villes sont restés concentrés à fond de
vallée c'est pour ça que
suisses peuvent avoir des trains
extrêmement efficace et très bien rempli
parce qu'il suffit d'avoir un truc qui
draine toutes les villes denses qui sont
restés en fond de vallée
donc ça marche très bien mais les
suisses ont de la chance c'est parce
qu'ils avaient des montagnes c'est pas
parce que ils ont été plus volontaires
que nous pour empêcher l'étalement
urbain
voilà la machine qui servent à étaler
les villes ça s'appelle des voitures
vous avez ici l'évolution du parc de
voitures en france depuis le début du
20e siècle et vous voyez que le l'après
guerre est caractérisé par une explosion
du parc de voitures en france c'est
l'explosion du pétrole et c'est
l'avènement de la liberté pour tous
alors le contrairement à ce qu'on pense
souvent quand on augmente la vitesse de
déplacement grâce à un engin motorisé
on ne diminue pas le temps de
déplacement on augmente la portée
ce qui s'est passé dans tous les pays
qui ont donné des voitures et des trains
et des avions
c'est pas que les gens se disent ah bah
comme ça va plus vite j'ai toujours
habité au même endroit travailler au
même endroit et je passerai moins de
temps dans les transports
les gens passent toujours la même
quantité de temps dans les transports
depuis que des statistiques depuis qu'il
ya des statistiques
les gens passent une heure par jour à se
déplacer pour aller pour leurs
déplacements contraints sur 3,2
déplacement en moyenne et la raison à ça
c'est qu'on est des animaux et que
l'animal sort de sa caverne pour aller
voir ce qui se passe ailleurs
donc un endroit dont vous n'avez jamais
droit de sortir s'appelle une prison et
en général on n'aime pas ça donc nous
sommes des animaux
nous sommes des hommes ont des désirs
sommes des êtres biologique et on sort
donc si on nous offre les moyens d'aller
plus loin
c'est ce qu'on fera voilà la
déplacements domicile travail moyen en
ile de france en 1975
voilà la même chose 2000 est-ce que les
gens utilisaient les voitures pour faire
les mêmes déplacements plus vite non ils
ont utilisé les voitures pour voyager le
même quand la même quantité de temps
plus loin l'idée qu'en améliorant la
performance des moyens de transport
on va permettre aux gens de se déplacer
moins longtemps est une illusion parce
que notre code génétique nous pousse à
faire autre chose donc
politique de transport utiles sont des
politiques dans lesquels on freine des
vitesses de déplacement désagréables
comme ça c'est exactement ça qu'il faut
faire
lorsque je vous ai montré pour la france
est vrai partout ici vous avez un pays
qui s'appelle l'inde dans lequel j'ai
mis alors c'est pas l'énergie que j'ai
pris cette co2 mais comme ces pays
utilisent que de l'énergie fossile c'est
pareil où vous avez ici l'emploi dans
l'agriculture et la les émissions de co2
par personne
eh bien vous voyez quand quelques
décennies à la faveur d'une émission de
co2 par personne c'est à dire d'une
quantité d'énergie par personne qui
augmente beaucoup et bien l'inde peut
diminuer fortement la quantité de gens
qui travaillent dans l'agriculture
voilà un autre pays un peu connu que la
chine
vous voyez exactement la même évolution
et voilà ce qui s'est passé pour le
monde dans son ensemble
c'est exactement la même évolution après
les gens sont allés dans les villes plus
il ya d'énergie plus il ya de gens dans
les villes ce qui veut dire soit dit en
passant qu un monde très urbanisé est un
monde non durables c'est un monde dans
lequel on ne saura pas quoi faire des
gens quand l'approvisionnement
énergétique décroîtra parce qu'on ne
pourra pas les laisser ni dans des
industries ni dans des services qui
dépendent du fait qu'on ait beaucoup
d'objets à manipuler à financer à
échanger et c'est donc c'est normal que
dans un monde où la quantité d'énergie
commence à devenir contraintes vous ayez
une déshérence économique croissante qui
apparaissent dans les villes et cette
déshérence économique croissante
apparaît en premier dans les zones des
villes qui sont les plus fragiles
quand l'énergie commence à manquer c'est
à dire les banlieues parce que c'est là
que les échanges se font le plus
difficilement demandes les plus grandes
distances donc ce qu'on est déjà en
train de voir apparaître à petite
échelle en france
la déshérence des banlieues n'est que la
conséquence logique de quelque chose que
je vais vous montrer un peu plus tard
qui est qu'en france on commence déjà à
avoir un approvisionnement énergétique
décroissant contre notre volonté donc
l'aménagement du territoire que nous
avons construit est un aménagement non
durables et pour rester dans le domaine
de l'enseignement le grand paris nous
sommes en train de faire en ce moment et
un truc anachronique et stupide le truc
qui est dans l'air du temps c'est de
faire le petit paris n'est pas de faire
le grand paris le grand paris est un
truc qui ne survit pas dans un monde à
l'énergie contraintes donc les pays qui
ont de plus en plus d'énergie donc de
plus en plus de co2 directement plus en
plus de co2 donc de plus en plus
d'énergie sur valises
voyez la chine voyez ici le brésil même
évolution
vous voyez ici la thaïlande voyez ici le
monde dans son ensemble
plus il ya d'énergie plus d'argent dans
les villes mais plus est instable parce
que ça pourra pas durer sans énergie
abondante
ce qui veut dire qu'un des sujets de
l'avenir
un des sujets qui sera celui des
ingénieurs dans cette salle plus tard
sera d'essayer de résoudre la très
difficile équation de savoir comment
faire pour sortir les gens des villes
ça va être un des problèmes qu'il va
falloir résoudre
et si on n'y arrive pas à temps on
retombera sur des régulations
désagréable des émeutes de la violence
etc et de la déshérence enfin ce que
vous voyez là c'est également que la
part de l'emploi dans les services
augmentent quand les émissions de co2
augmente donc les des sympathiques qui
est que pour baisser les émissions de
co2 il faudrait augmenter le nombre de
gens dans un bureau correspond
exactement à l'inversé de ce qui
s'observe pour baisser les émissions de
co2 il faut sortir les gens des bureaux
très mauvaise nouvelle pour moi qui
travaille soit dit en passant
sortir les landais bureau parce que plus
deux ans jean d'un bureau c'est plus
d'objets en gros c'est plus de gens pour
gérer des flux dont plus de flux si vous
n'avez pas de flux vous avez pas besoin
d'en pas besoin de gens dans les bureaux
encore une fois à l'époque d'astérix il
y avait pas beaucoup de gens dans les
bureaux sauf les trois légionnaires
romains dont ils se fichent quand il va
se faire embaucher
mais s'il n'y en a pas
voilà donc ça c'est pour les gens dans
les bureaux en chine en fonction des
émissions de co2 ici vous avez ça pour
le brésil
ici vous avez ça pour tous les pays
émergents est ici vous avez ça pour le
monde donc je résume tout ce que je vous
ai dit jusqu'à maintenant
l'énergie c'est notre costume de
superman notre costume de superman
permet de baisser les gens qui
travaillent à nourrir permet d'augmenter
les gens qui travaillent à transformer
n'importe quoi d'autre qui se trouvent
en ville et les gens qui derrière gère
cette production physique qui se
trouvent en ville et c'est ça qui est le
fait des deux derniers siècles à vitesse
extrêmement accéléré alors question ce
que je suis en train de vous dire
pourquoi est ce que le monde économique
que nous avons l'habitude de manipuler
ne reflète pas ce que je viens d'évoquer
qui relève de l'observation physique
tout bête et bien la raison elle est la
voix si c'est parce qu'au moment où se
crée l'économie classique dont j'ai mis
très longtemps à comprendre pourquoi je
ne comprenais rien à l'économie
pendant très longtemps je me suis dit
que j'étais totalement stupide en fait
j'ai fini par comprendre
le jour où j'ai compris que l'économie
était une approximation au premier ordre
qui avait cessé d'être valable dans le
monde moderne et à partir de ce moment
là j'ai compris que du coup l'économie
racontait des tas de conneries tout
simplement parce que ce n'était pas une
convention adaptée au système à décrire
et à ce moment là j'ai été très rassurés
de comprendre pourquoi je ne comprenais
rien alors pourquoi je ne comprenais
rien c'est à cause de lui et de ses
petits copains
il ya deux siècles il ya deux siècles
l'économie falaise et l'école d'economie
naissante qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'économie classique vous dit quand on
va s'intéresser à l'économie c'est à
dire la production on va s'intéresser à
ce qui est limite ans pour la production
du autrement on va pas s'intéresser à
modéliser des trucs qui ne sont pas
limitant on voit pas pourquoi donc on va
juste se concentrer sur des choses qui
sont limitantes même si elle si si ça
n'est pas la totalité des choses
nécessaires et ce qui est limite ans il
ya deux siècles
c'est essentiellement ce qui dépend des
hommes il ya deux siècles je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure on est un peu
moins d'un milliard
on a une active productivité
individuelle assez faibles on sait même
pas que l'antarctique existe l'amérique
commence à être colonisés mais pas
depuis très longtemps et c'est le monde
est immense en connaît absolument pas
tous les océans et à ce moment là les
économistes disent bon ce qui est limite
ans et ce qui dépend des hommes
le reste n'est pas la peine de s'en
occuper et donc ne pas la peine de s'en
occuper
si je convertis ça en termes
mathématiques ça veut dire que ça vaut
zéro quand on sait pas la peine de
s'occuper ça vaut zéro c'est invisible
dans les équations à ce moment là les
économistes modélise le système comme
suit ils vous disent on a un système
productif
les deux facteurs limitant donc les deux
qui pilote la production c'est le
capital et le travail humain et si vous
avez du capital et du travail up bd tôt
fait de bonnes affaires et le
supermarché est rempli voilà ton suffit
d'y autrement pour avoir tout ce qui
remplit le supermarché il suffit que
j'ai des gens au travail et des
banquiers compatissant alors là dessus
l'ingénieur que vous êtes et que je suis
arrivé en disant ce monsieur madame tous
les éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
l'ass qui sont contenus dans mes objets
à droite j'ai bien été obligé de les
prendre quelque part parce que harry
potter n'est pas capable de faire
apparaître de l'énergie mais il n'est
pas plus capable de faire apparaître des
atomes de cuivre or il faut bien qu'ils
les prennent quelque part les atomes de
cuivre de même qui doit bien apprendre
quelque part le carbone l'oxygène et
l'hydrogène et c est donc pour que vous
ayez des objets vous êtes obligés
d'avoir les ressources qui composent ces
objets est obligé d'aller prendre les
ressources dans la nature pour les
transformer en produits
vous n'avez pas une bouteille en verre
dans un supermarché sans que vous ayez
le sable et le carbonate que vous avez
utilisé pour faire le vert vous n'êtes
pas capable d'avoir une paire de
lunettes chez l'opticien sans avoir le
métal qui va vous permettre de faire les
branches de lunettes
vous n'êtes pas capable de faire une
campagne publicitaire sans avoir les
ressources naturelles qui vous
permettent de faire le papier
plus l'acier qui vous permet de faire
l'imprimante plus le bois qui vous
permet de faire le mange du ballet plus
la colle qui vous permet aux parfums qui
permet aux poseurs d'affichés de coller
la fiche 1
pas plus que vous n'êtes capable de
faire un très bel écran publicitaire de
jean claude decaux n'en parlons pas de
marque qui maintenant vous agressent
dans le métro en vous expliquant qu'il
est absolument indispensable d'acheter
quelque chose
donc vous avez besoin des ressources
pour avoir les objets à l'arrivée même
quand vous êtes dans les services
cet établissement d'enseignement qui
dans les services a besoin de ressources
il a fallu construire ce bâtiment
sinon la conférence d'aujourd'hui se
serait faite sous la flotte est en plein
air ça aurait été pas sûr qu'il y aurait
autant de monde dans les salles
vous avez besoin de chaises parce que si
vous deviez rester debout finiriez par
avoir mal aux jambes est allé boire un
café vous avez besoin d'un micro parce
que sinon je braille ray et même un
verre d'eau n'y suffiraient pas et c'est
donc vous avez besoin même dans les
services de ressources transformé pour
être capable d'exercer votre activité
toutes les activités productives
humaines ont besoin de ressources il
vous avez besoin de la capacité à les
transformer qu'ils s'appellent du
travail on revient à la physique le
travail c'est la transformation et cette
transformation elle est assurée un peu
par nous essentiellement par des
machines
donc là je vous fait apparaître deux
autres facteurs limitants potentiel de
l'activité humaine les ressources
transformable et la capacité à les
transformer via le parc de machines le
capital existe bien
donc le travail existe bien dans cette
représentation est là c'est la capacité
à transformer mais il n'est pas limité
aux hommes le capital existe bien
également dans cette représentation
c'est juste des ressources qu'on a
utilisé pour faire des biens qui ne ce
qui ne se détruisent pas quand on s'en
sert donc la différence entre la
production d'un bien de consommation un
paquet de gâteaux qui se détruit quand
vous en servez quand vous mangez votre
paquet de gâteaux comme disent les
anglais vous pouvez pas manger votre
gâteau et la voir après le
détruits et bien la différence c'est que
si l'immeuble dans lequel nous sommes
ceux détruits pendant qu'on s'en sert
donc s'effondre sur doux pendant cette
conférence on met le directeur de
l'école on ne peut pas le mettre en
taule en ce moment puisqu'il n'a pas
mettre à l'adjoint et parce que le
capital n'est pas censé se détruire
quand on s'en sert voilà mais c'est la
seule différence sinon c'est des
ressources naturelles transformer comme
maurice si vous avez un alors pour
moment vous verrez qu'il n'ya pas encore
de facteurs limitants sur l'énergie
globalement donc tout ça marche très
bien mais le jour où vous en avez un à
ce moment vous avez un facteur limitant
sur la production donc tout de suite
j'arrive à quelque chose sur lequel je
reviendrai plus tard limiter la pression
environnementale est limitée en
particulier la quantité de croquettes
pour machines que nous utilisons c'est
par construction quand ça devient
significatif récessif les grosses
économies d'énergie sont récessive par
construction c'est pour ça que le slogan
de l'ademe
on s'assied dessus autant qu'on peut
autant qu'on peut parce que la meilleure
énergie est bien celle qu'on consomme
puisque c'est celle qui permet de faire
du pib donc la meilleure énergie n'est
absolument pas celle qu'on ne consomme
pas c'est celle qu'on pense à et si vous
manquez de ressources vous aurez un
sujet sur la production alors prenons
par exemple une activité qui s'exerce
pas très loin d'ici qui s'appelle la
pêche pour aller à la pêche
vous n'avez pas besoin juste d'un crédit
maritime compatissant et juste de marins
prêt à aller en découdre en chantant des
chansons paillardes
vous avez aussi besoin de poissons et
vous avez également besoin d'énergie car
le chalutier moderne à la ram ça ne
marche pas très bien il suffit pas
d'avoir quelques galets rien pour faire
avancer la barque
donc vous avez aujourd'hui besoin de
tout ça si vous n'avez plus de fioul à
mettre dans votre chalutiers et bien le
produit de la pêche est nul
et si par ailleurs vous n'avez plus les
poissons qui apparaissent dans la mer
spontanément puisque les poissons baisse
dedans comme vous le savez mais tout à
fait gratuitement et bien vous n'avez
pas non plus de produits de la pêche
donc le produit de la pêche dépendent de
ressources naturelles qui ne sont pas
dans l'équation les poissons qui sont
gratuits dans la convention et le
pétrole dont vous allez voir un peu plus
tard qu'il est gratuit aussi sol coûtant
quelque chose le fait de l'extraire
alors aujourd'hui mondialement nous
n'avons pas encore de facteurs limitants
sur l'énergie est pas encore sur les
ressources ça arrive encore et vous
voyez que la production humaine depuis
la naissance de monsieur jésus-christ
alors c'est l'an 1 c'est pas le zéro
puisque on passe de -1 dans le
calendrier mais peu importe a été
pendant qu'on n'avait pas beaucoup de
machines essentiellement elle a pas
bougé
cette production humaine donc temps que
la le parc de machines restent très
faibles et bien la production humaine ne
varie quasiment pas elle varie au rythme
de l'accroissement de population qui sur
cette période là n'est pas extrêmement
élevé et puis arrive nos esclaves des
temps modernes et les croquettes pour la
chine et à ce moment nous inventons la
croissance structurelle de long terme
qui va sauver vos retraites
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour tous
les étudiants dans cette salle ça ne
sera pas le cas dans le plan de
sauvetage des retraites actuellement en
discussion
est ce que vous savez quel est le
pourcentage de croissance du pib qui est
supposé entre maintenant et 2005 ans et
2070 dans les 50 ans qui viennent
non vous exagérez un peu entre 1 et 2%
par an 1,5 de quoi donc pendant les 50
ans qui viennent nous allons avoir
l'économie en croissance est ce que
c'est le résultat d'une démonstration
mathématique
pas du tout c'est juste la manière dont
il faut ajuster le potentiomètre pour
que le truc marche
donc on met le potentiomètre sur 1,5 en
se disant c'est ça qui va se passer
ou plus exactement en faisant croire que
c'est ça qui va se passer non la
croissance sera ce que sera
l'approvisionnement énergétique français
qui sur les 50 ans qui viennent ne
permettra absolument pas d'avoir une
économie qui augmente de 2 5% par an
absolument pas donc le sauvetage des
retraites on va le faire tous les saints
puis tous les deux ans tu vois là je
vous rappelle qu'avant l'époque de
l'énergie abondante les retraites y en
avait pas y avait pas de système de
retraite
je reste avant l'énergie abondante y
avait pas besoin d'avoir un système de
retraite puisque l'espérance de vie à la
naissance il ya deux siècles c'était 25
ans dans les villes et 30 ans la
campagne qu'il n'avait pas de problème
de retraite il y avait peu de gens à la
retraite donc ce qui a permis aux gens
de passer à la retraite c'est l'énergie
abondante aussi donc vous voyez là que
nous sommes partis avec un taux de
croissance observé depuis quelques cirfa
depuis deux siècles qui est très fort
mais ça va pas durer l'éternité
évidemment si je fais un zoom sur une
période plus courte qui est les 60
dernières années
voilà à quoi ça ressemble vous avez ici
à une courbe qui est obtenue de la
manière suivante pour chaque point entre
1965 et 2018 chez pendant les
statistiques pour 2019
j'ai mis sur l'axé horizontal la
quantité de croquettes pour machines
qu'on utilise c'est à dire le parc de
machines en service et sur l'axé
vertical
la contrepartie économique ce qu'on
appelle le pib de la production humaine
et bien vous voyez que le meilleur
modèle macroéconomique au monde
s'appelle une droite droite tout simple
à comprendre mais montmirail une droite
dieu autrement c'est très simple dis moi
combien de croquettes pour machine tu as
je te dirai combien de machines
fonctionnent et dont je te dirai quel
état production donc quand les
dirigeants politiques vous dise c'est
une affaire la richesse le pib de taux
de prélèvements obligatoires de chevaux
bullshit
quand vous faites des analyses
statistiques dans le monde
il n'y a pas le moindre lien que vous
puissiez l'établir par exemple entre la
croissance du pib et le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires
pas le moindre les pays scandinaves qui
était historiquement des pays avec des
taux de prélèvements obligatoires
extrêmement élevés ont eu des taux de
croissance extrêmement élevé y a pas le
moindre lien ça c'est du bullshit
intégral les taux de prélèvements
obligatoires exprime juste là
préférences collectives pour la part du
public dans l'économie
voilà c'est ça que ça exprime le top
obligatoire absolument pas le fait que
ça va freiner ou pas freiner la
production
aucune espèce d'importance la suède à
des taux de prélèvements obligatoires
extrêmement élevé et un commerce et
international extrêmement développée
donc c'est pas il n'y a pas de lien
entre les deux par contre en quantité
d'énergie qui rentre dans le pays et le
pib alors ça oui il ya un lien direct et
comme l'essentiel de cette énergie et
fossiles voici nos drames des
négociations climat dont vous allez voir
un peu plus tard c'est pas des
négociations soit dit en passant c'est
que aujourd'hui le pib répond aussi de
manière linéaire à la quantité de co2
émise c'est à dire à la quantité de
machines mises en service dans la
convention climat dans la convention
climat qui soit dit en passant fait de
tous les étudiants dans cette salle des
générations futures
puisque la convention climat qui date de
1992 parlait de générations futures et
si le dictionnaire est bien fait une
génération future en 1992 c'est tous les
gens qui vont être après 1992 d'accord
avec moi tous les gens à naître en 1992
font partie des générations futures donc
dans cette salle il ya essentiellement
des générations futures voire près futur
donc les générations futures c'est vous
t'es pas besoin d'aller les chercher
chez pas ou non un joël non c'est toi
tous étaient cuites moi aussi mais sinon
les générations futures c'est vous
d'accord
donc le dans la convention climat soit
dit en passant il est marqué que on doit
à la fois préserver le climat
on doit préserver les générations
futures mais sans nuire au développement
te décris d'accord
ce qui veut dire que la conséquence de
ça c'est comme me l'a dit un jour brice
lalonde qui est un des vétérans de la
faire dans ce pays
il m'a dit ça fait donc trente ans que
les enfin un peu moins de 30 ans que les
pays développés et viennent dans ce
genre d'endroit en pensant qu'on va
parler de climat que les pays en
développement viennent en pensant qu'on
va parler de développement et que c'est
ceux en développement qui gagne dix
autres avant tout c'est moi ce climat de
là on va parler de pib et donc on ne
parle pas de clients enfin si on en
parle mais on ne fait rien
on y viendra pas voilà donc l'histoire
des 19e et 20e siècles peut se résumer
de la manière suivante nous avons sous
terre des combustibles fossiles qui ont
une caractéristique c'est qu'ils sont
gratuits
comme toutes les ressources naturelles
sur terre donc les poissons sont
gratuits le pétrole est gratuit il
raconte n'importe quoi l'essence à la
pompe et les fidji au pétrole et gratuit
le vent est gratuit quand vous avez tous
entendu il n'y a pas de raison de pas se
servir du vent il est gratuit mais le
pétrole est gratuit qui dans cette salle
à payer le moindre centime pour que le
pétrole existe personnes qui sur terre à
payer le moindre centime pour que le
pétrole existe personnes donc dans le
cas du pétrole comme dans le cas du vent
la seule chose qui coûte c'est les gens
qui vont devoir travailler pour sortir
l'énergie de l'environnement
l'argent n'achète que les hommes et les
femmes un peu moins sont vénales donc
mais sinon l'argent n'achète que les
hommes
donc l'argent n'achète pas les
ressources naturelles qui sont gratuites
par convention donc le pétrole est
gratuit le charbon est gratuit le gaz
est gratuit les chutes d'eau sont
gratuites
l'uranium est gratuit et les mines de
cuivre sont gratuites tout ça c'est
gratuit tout ce qui coûte à chaque fois
c'est les gens qui vont devoir se mettre
au travail pour aller chercher les
ressources et les gens qui vont devoir
consentir à s'en défaire si ils ont la
chance d'être assis dessus l'autre
variante est temps de leur envoyer des
chars et les avions pour se l'approprier
chose que nous avons abondamment fait
dans l'histoire mais la ressource elle
même est toujours gratuite
quelle qu'elle soit et donc quand vous
avez sous terre une ressource gratuite
beaucoup plus concentrés qu'une autre
ressource gratuite qui est le vent il va
vous falloir moins de travail humain
pour aller chercher la ressource
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
passé des énergies renouvelables au
pétrole
pour ça il est juste pour cent
donc ce pétrole ce gaz charbon brûle ce
qui permet de mettre en oeuvre des
machines qui transforme tout ce qui nous
tombe sous la main de fer tous les
objets que nous avons à portée de main
et de faire la structure socio
économique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui avec comme je le disais tout
à l'heure les études longues les congés
payés
tout ça c'est une allocation du temps
qu'on a plus besoin de travail et les
congés payés les études longues les
retraites les 35 heures les week-ends
tout ça c'est une allocation etc rien de
tout ça n'existait à l'époque où
l'énergie était contrainte on possède
toute la semaine juste d'aller à la
messe le dimanche on n'avait pas de
vacances c'est apparu en 1936 on n'avait
pas d'études longues
et on mourait trop jeune pour avoir de
retraite donc tout ça est apparu avec
l'énergie augmentent
on a également une convention qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui au détriment toutes
les autres pour conter cette affaire qui
s'appelle le pib ou l'économie qui
mesurent économiquement la
transformation on pourrait tout aussi
bien mesurer les kilowattheures
maintenant je vais vous parler
rapidement de deux goulets
d'étranglement donc y en a plein je
pourrais vous parler de la limitation
sur le cuivre je pourrais vous parler de
la limitation sur les espèces rares et
c'est un jeu où concentrer sur nos
limites qui sont des limites que de
toute façon on va devoir gérer la
première celle exutoire à l'aval de
cette affaire
donc en brûlant tout un tas de trucs qui
contiennent du carbone la chili et en
reine ont fait du co2 il ya pas qu
vraiment moyen d'y échapper
et ce co2 va dans une grande poubelle
qui s'appelle l'atmosphère
historiquement les hommes n'ont eu que
deux manières de gérer leurs déchets en
les concentrant et en les isolant
typiquement c'est ce qu'on fait avec les
substances chimiques très dangereuse les
déchets nucléaires etc ou bien en les
dispersant dans l'environnement et en se
disant l'environnement va épurer pour
nous c'est typiquement ce qu'on fait
avec le co2 sauf que ça marche pas bien
l'environnement les pleurent pas pendant
et vous avez également un goulet
d'étranglement à l'amont qui est que les
combustibles fossiles n'étant pas
renouvelable
eh bien on va voir tout de suite que les
mathématiques nous impose que nous
n'allons pas en avoir indéfiniment de
plus en plus parce qu'effectivement si
je tape dans une ressource qui n'est pas
renouvelable
alors je vais traduire ça en langage
mathématique ça veut dire que je tape
dans une ressource dont le stock de
départ est prescrit une fois pour toute
et donc l'extraction cumulé de moins
d'un fils y aplus l'infini ne peut pas
dépasser une certaine valeur encore
d'accord avec moi si je tape dans un
stock de départ qui est donnée une fois
pour toutes ça revient à dire que
l'intégrale de la fonction d'extraction
ne peut pas dépasser une certaine valeur
à les bornes et elle est finie elle
existe
à ce moment les mathématiques vous
disent que simon intégral le moins
l'infini à plus infinie existe pour une
fonction positive et intégrables eh bien
je ne peux ni avoir une valeur moyenne
ce que vous pouvez voir des d'irak nie
avoir une valeur moyenne qui augmente
indéfiniment d'antan dix autres avant je
ne peux pas avoir une extraction annuel
qui augmente indéfiniment autant les
mathématiques me l'interdisent très
facile à démontrer par l'absurde très
facile à démontrer par l'absurde
toujours je ne peux même pas avoir une
extraction qui restent indéfiniment
constante est toujours facile à
démontrer par l'absurde je sais encore
le faire en fait dans ce genre de cas de
figure vous êtes obligés d'avoir une
fonction qui tend vers zéro à moins y'a
plus l'infini et qui passe par un
maximum absolu entre les deux corps
c'est juste un théorème de maths
donc quand vous tapez dans un stock de
départ qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes qu'il s'agisse de pétrole de gaz
de charbon et de minerais de cuivre de
tantale de chrome de vanadium de pâques
stand aluminium
whatever vous aurait nécessairement un
maximum absolu à l'extraction ça marche
aussi pour l'or et les diamants je suis
désolé qui s'appelle le pic est
nécessairement essaie pas de l'idéologie
c'est un théorème de maths
après le bon le bon débat c'est est ce
que c'est loin est ce que s'est passé
est ce que c'est devant est ce que ces
os que sebbah et est-ce que c'est grave
et est-ce qu'on doit le provoquer ou est
ce qu'on doit attendre qu'ils arrivent
tout seul
ça c'est des bons éléments du débat le
fait qu'il n'y en aura pas c'est juste
essayé de violer un théorème de maths ça
naoko tant de sens que dire que la terre
est plate
il y aura un pic alors quand je dis que
les combustibles fossiles sont non
renouvelable ce n'est pas tout à fait
vrai ils le sont un peu ils le sont un
peu parce que en quelques millions à
quelques centaines de millions d'années
vous reformé du pétrole mais bon aux
échelles de temps historique
on va dire que quelques centaines de
millions d'années ça nous concerne pas
vraiment donc au premier ordre
c'est non renouvelables points et pour
les minerais c'est totalement non
renouvelable alors est-ce que le pic de
production est loin devant
eh bien j'ai une bonne nouvelle il est
loin derrière pour une large partie du
pétrole qui s'appelle le pétrole
conventionnel pour le pétrole dits
conventionnels
c'est à dire tout ce qui n'est pas le
pétrole de roche-mère qu'on appelle le
chez lloyd pétrole de schiste tout ça
c'est pareil aux états unis celui qui
s'obtient en fracturant la roche et tout
ce qui n'est pas les sables bitumineux
du canada donc les saloperies qu'on
exploite à ciel ouvert enfin maintenant
également sous sol mais c'est bien pour
tout ce qui n'est pas ça la production
de pétrole dans le monde est passé par
un maximum en 2008 et depuis elle
décline alors 2008 ça vous rappellera
peut-être quelque chose il ya eu un tout
petit peu de remous économiques
en 2008 le ou d'ouvriers ou dans
souvenirs même si vous n'êtes pas très
vieux dans cette salle en fait c'est
normal qu'il y ait eu ce rapport de
cause à conséquence
parce que comme le pétrole et ceux qui
alimentent la totalité des moyens de
transport
c'est à dire la totalité des flux des
changes entre composants intermédiaire
du système économique
si vous avez moins de pétrole disponible
vous aurez moins de flux des changes
entre composants du système et donc vous
aurez moins de production au sein de
toutes les énergies
le pétrole et l'énergie qui est la plus
limitantes pour le système économique
et vous vous en rendez compte avec le
graphique que je vous montre maintenant
dans lequel en rouge vous avez la
variation de la quantité de pétrole qui
sort de terre chaque année et ample vous
avez la variation du pib par personne
chaque année sur terre
et bien ce que vous voyez c'est que le
meilleur modèle prédictif que vous ayez
aujourd'hui pour l'économie c'est pas
d'aller demander aux économistes de l'
ocde ou du fmi ou de la banque de france
ou de je sais pas qui ce qui va se
passer les années qui viennent c'est de
demander aux pétroliers c'est dur je
vous préviens parce que des informations
sont pas publics il faut les faire
beaucoup boire mais c'est de demander
aux pétroliers combien de pétrole
devrait vraisemblablement sortir des
puits dans les années qui viennent
et là vous avez votre prévision pour le
pib ça marche beaucoup mieux je vous
assure joue aujourd'hui j'ai pas bon
enfin j'ai pas suffisamment de temps
dont je vous montre pas mais j'ai des
tas de courbes qui vous montre comment a
évolué la production économique mondiale
versus ce qui avait été prévu quelques
années auparavant par les économistes
si vous avez envie de rigoler un grand
coup regardez ça est ainsi si on faisait
les avions n'empêche avec le même genre
de modèle il y en aurait pas un qui
atterrirait sans tuer tout le monde
alors les ingénieurs qui font ça en les
fois la porte on les prenne en justice
les économistes qui font ça on continue
à les écouter on veut donc ici vous avez
le meilleur modèle qui fonctionne et
vous voyez que on est bien dans une
relation de cause à conséquence parce
que la variation sur le pétrole quand ya
un décalage chronologique survient avant
la variation sur le pib
on n'est donc pas dans un monde dans
lequel le pib augmenterait parce que ça
vient de mars et à ce moment on n'a plus
d'argent et on achète plus de pétrole
on est bien dans un monde dans lequel si
on est physiquement capable d'extraire
plus ou moins de pétrole
à ce moment on aura une économie qui va
répondre en augmentant ou en baissant
applications pratiques
vous avez ici l'approvisionnement
pétrolier de l'europe
alors là privilégiant pétrolier de
l'europe vient de deux sources le
pétrole de la mer du nord que vous avez
en rose sur ce graphique et puisque
c'est essentiel fins et pour beaucoup du
pétrole anglais
comme vous le savez l'angleterre c'est
la rose avant le parti socialiste est
ici vous avez le pétrole qui est importé
du moyen-orient qui est vert puisque
c'est une des couleurs de l'islam
donc non je plaisante vous avez ici donc
le pétrole qui est importé ou pas que du
moyen-orient soit dit en passant est ici
pétrole de la mer du nord
ce que vous voyez c'est qu'au moment des
chocs pétroliers dont en 74 et 79 nous
passons par un maximum historique à
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de
l'europe mais si vous essayez de lisser
cette courbe aux voiliers class à vendre
plus vite une tendance là ça pèse que
plus mais la tendance c'est qu'en fait
ça monte ça monte ça monte ça monte ça
monte ça monte ça monte
et là ça passe par un maximum dans le
cadre d'un truc un peu réguliers et puis
depuis sa baisse
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2006
il s'est passé le début de du plateau de
production débouchant ensuite sur le pic
de production en 2008 du pétrole
conventionnel et donc à ce moment là
l'europe a de plus en plus de mal à
importer du pétrole parce qu'il ya de
moins en moins de pétrole conventionnel
dans le monde et que le shale oil des
américains essentiellement ils se
gardent par ailleurs vous avez des pays
qui subventionnent leur carburant qui
eux continuent à en importer plus en
plus typiquement la chine l'indonésie
etc l'inde est à ce moment il y en a de
moins en moins pour les européens donc
la mer du nord a passé son pic en 2000
les approvisionnements en provenance de
l'étranger passent leur pic en 2006 et
du coup ça décline là vous avez l'effet
rebond qui est lié au fait que les prix
du pétrole ayant fortement augmenté
les pétroliers ont mis un peu plus de
moyens pour aller racler les fonds de
tiroir et les américains ont commencé à
faire des trous partout
les etats unis ces deux pays plus troué
au monde vous avez plus d'un million de
puits de pétrole et de gaz actif en ce
moment aux états unis et ils on rajoute
des dizaines de milliers de chaque côté
chaque année c'est des rois du trou
gainsbourg devait être américain et
donc vous avez ici l'effet d'une
augmentation du prix du pétrole et de la
frénésie 30 de nos amis américains
mais vous voyez que ça marche aussi pour
la mer du nord à cause du prix très
élevés du pétrole les grands écolo
norvégiens ont un peu mieux racler les
fonds de tiroir et produit un peu plus
de pétrole
mais en europe pour conjuguer avec
d'autres facteurs qui sont locaux et qui
nous complique également la vie ici vous
avez l'approvisionnement gazier en
europe et vous remarqué que l'europe en
tout d'un coup à sa consommation de gaz
qui s'arrêtent d'augmenter pourquoi
est-ce qu'on devient écolo en 2005 tout
d'un coup pas du tout en 2005 la
production de gaz de la mer du nord
passe son pic depuis elle décline or le
gaz est en gazon de ses caractéristiques
il est beaucoup moins denses par unité
de volume que le pétrole par beaucoup
moins dense énergétiquement transport
beaucoup moins d'énergie par unité de
volume ce qui veut dire que la
déperdition énergétique de la chaîne
logistique du gaz est beaucoup plus
élevé et donc c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué à transporter sur des grandes
distances
65 % du pétrole extrait dans le monde
passe une frontière entre le pays de
consommation et le pays de production
exactement entre le pays de production
et le pays consommation ça n'est vrai
que pour 30% du gaz et pour le vrai gaz
mondialisé le gnl qui peut aller partout
partout sur terre c'est vrai pour moins
de 10 % du gaz
donc quand vous avez du gaz qui commence
à faire défaut
régionalement en importer de manière
massive en provenance d'autres pays pour
compenser ce déclin
c'est compliqué et donc au moment où la
mer du nord passe son pic de production
l'europe s'arrête de consommer de plus
en plus de gaz et semer en sauvait de
moins en moins ce qui veut dire soit dit
en passant qu'une d'un des grands rêves
des antinucléaires qui est de remplacer
la production électrique par du gaz et
de l'éolien s'est pas complètement sûr
qu'on ait diaz indépendamment du fait
que ça crachera plus de co2 pas
complètement sûr en éclats
et si on faisait des trous partout comme
les américains voilà l'ordre de grandeur
de ce qu'on ferait sortir chez nous
c'est pas à la mesure du problème
indépendamment du fait que je pense pas
que ce soit une très bonne idée
enfin nous avons du charbon en europe
mais comme ça fait deux siècles
comptable dans nos mines
nous en avons aujourd'hui de moins en
moins et ce moins en moins date de bien
avant que le problème climat ne devienne
quelque chose dans la conscience des
gens
la production de charbon en europe alors
sur ce graphique je vous vois vous le
voyez pas mais est passé par un maximum
dans les années 60
et depuis ça décline la france a fermé
ces dernières mines dans les années 90
donc le la grande bretagne a fermé ses
mines etc
l'allemagne n'a quasiment plus de
charbon au sens où y
ce qui lui reste c'est de la limite qui
est un charbon de mauvaise qualité qui
s'exploitent dans des mines à ciel
ouvert qui sont par ailleurs des
horreurs environnementale mais
l'allemagne aujourd'hui importe la
quasi-totalité de ce qu'on appelle le
hard cole sert de la wii ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphique donc c'est que la
production européenne depuis des années
80 a été divisé quasiment par quatre et
comme la chaîne logistique du charbon
est aussi une horreur absolue parce que
le charbon est un pont d'hérault solide
donc il faut des trains dédié des
terminaux portuaires dédié des ports
dédiés 2 x 2 watts et c'est un truc très
compliqué quand vous avez de moins en
moins de charbon chez vous c'est
compliqué d'en apporter de manière
massive en provenance du reste du monde
la consommation de charbon est
essentiellement une consommation
domestique dans le monde pour le charbon
qui alimente les centrales électriques
au charbon vapeur 90 % de la
consommation mondiale est fait dans le
pays qui a produit le charbon donc en
france on croit que le charbon a disparu
tout simplement parce qu'il n'a pas chez
nous mais c'est pareil
les pays qui ont du charbon consomment
leurs chambres et soit dit en passant
huit pays dans le monde possèdent
environ 90% du charbon mondiale et ces
pays sont respectivement dans l'ordre si
ma mémoire est bonne les états unis
possède les premières réserves de
charbon au monde
ensuite vous allez trouver la chine
ensuite vous allez trouver je ne sais
plus dans quel ordre l'inde et
l'australie
pendant exactement dans quel ordre puis
vous allez trouver le kazakhstan
l'indonésie l'afrique du sud la pologne
e
il y en a encore un cheptel et voilà
donc une fois que j'ai fait le tour de
ces pays
j'ai fait à peu près le tour de 90% du
charbon mondiale ce qui veut dire que
ces pays-là détiennent une large partie
de l'avenir du climat entre leurs mains
et qui va falloir les convaincre de ne
pas utiliser chez eux
le charbon qu'ils ont chez eux pour sa
faudra payer
c'est évident que si vous devez
convaincre quelqu'un de ne pas utiliser
chez lui un truc qu'il a chez lui ou
bien voulu envoyer les chars et les
avions mais avec les états unis et la
chine s'avère compliqué ah oui
j'oubliais la russie pardon deuxième
produit deuxième détenteur de réserves
la russie c'est compliqué aussi napoléon
essayer ça pas bien réussi
donc voilà donc la russie est le
deuxième détenteur de réserves de
charbon dont ces pays là doivent ne pas
utiliser chez eux le charbon qu'ils ont
chez eux
voilà c'est ça le sujet est à l'enjeu
revient en europe vous avez ici la
quantité de croquettes pour machines par
européen depuis un bon demi siècle
c'est-à-dire 1965 et bien vous voyez que
la quantité de croquettes pour machines
des européens augmentent jusqu'à au
moment des chocs pétroliers
les chocs pétroliers marque un brutal
changement de dérivés c'est à dire
l'arrêt de la hausse de la quantité de
croquettes pour machines par personne
donc ça marque un brutal arrêt du nombre
de machines en fonctionnement par
personne modulo l'efficacité énergétique
que les brillantes cervelle dans cette
salle arriverons à faire sur les
machines en question
sauf que même si vous êtes de très
brillants de cervelle la physique vous
met des bâtons dans les roues et il ya
plein d'endroits où elle vous impose des
limites non franchissable par exemple
vous ne ferez jamais mieux que 1 - t2 /
t1 avec un moteur thermique
vous avez beau être major de promo etc
vous irez pas au dessus de la moité de
sûreté un vous n'irez jamais au dessus
de l'énergie minimale d'écrasement d'une
brave d'acier quand vous êtes dans un
ami noir
voilà vous irez pas au dessus vous ou
plus exactement de l'énergie de
réarrangement des atomes dans une brave
d'acier
j'ai pas le droit vous pouvez pas vous
irez jamais en dessous dont 1/2 de mv2
pour l'énergie qui met en mouvement une
voiture j'allais peut vous en rapprocher
diminuer les frottements etc
mais vous irez jamais en dessous de 1 2
me de mv2 donc le gain d'efficacité
énergétique à partir des chocs
pétroliers est trop faible
chaque année pour permettre au pib
d'augmenter comme avant on pib par
personne
parce qu'avant ce qu'ils faisaient
augmenter le pib par personne c'est l
augmentation du parc de machines par
personnes essentiellement c'est à dire
l'augmentation des croquettes
énergétique par personne et apparition à
ce moment dans tous les pays occidentaux
de deux problèmes qu'on nous avons
toujours sur les bras donc un la
pyramide de ponzi de la dette qui
démarre à ce moment là qui ne s'est
jamais résorber qui n'a jamais cessé
d'augmenter et qui ne sera jamais
remboursé jusqu'à maintenant la seule
manière que nous avons trouvé de
rembourser la dette
c'est d'en rajouter par dessus pour
rembourser la précédente il n'y a que
deux manières de finir il ya qu une
seule manière pardon de finir l'histoire
c'est de ne pas rembourser les gens qui
ont de la dette publique qui possède la
dette et il ya que deux manières de
faire
la première un peu brutale s'appelle le
défaut c'est les emprunts russes
tiens overnight on vous dit ben on vous
remboursera point bas voilà j'avais un
truc vous à vous aviez un actif là vous
aviez de l'assurance vie vous aviez des
obligations d'état d'assurance vie ben
votre truc vous 0 alors ça c'est un
transfert instantané de richesse des
vieux vers les jeunes que c'est les
vieux cons d'assurance vie c'est les
jeunes qui rembourse donc un transfert
instantané de richesse des lieux vers
les jeunes c'est d'arrêter de rembourser
d'assurance face et c'est que les états
fassent défaut ça marche très bien
la deuxième manière de ne pas rembourser
c'est d'avoir une inflation supérieure
au rendement de l'argent ce qui est déjà
en train de se passer avec l'inflation
qui est supérieur au tour du livret a et
les taux d'intérêts négatifs on commence
à voir apparaître sur les obligations
d'état et les obligations d'entreprises
donc est en train de se mettre en ce
moment un système
pas de manière délibérée qui correspond
juste au fait que physiquement ça suit
plus qui est un système d'érosion du
patrimoine financier et ça ne peut se
terminer que comme ça ça ne peut se
terminer que comme ça donc un jour il y
aura des défauts je sais pas si ça sera
la france l'italie l'espagne
un jour il y aura des défauts et il y
aura de plus en plus des taux négatifs
donc là vous voyez le début de la dette
et le début du chômage comme les
croquettes pour machines par personne
n'augmente plus et bien le nombre de
machines par personne n'augmentent pas
par contre la taille des machines
augmente et donc on a de moins en moins
de gens à mettre derrière des machines
et on commence à avoir après le chômage
alors le problème de chômage a été
résolue d'une des deux manière suivante
dans tous les pays occidentaux
soit je fais apparaître des travailleurs
pauvres ça c'est la voix libérales les
anglais les allemands les américains les
allemands soit je mets les gens au
chômage et je les fait vivre grâce aux
frais de la collectivité
c'est la voix française mais c'est l'un
ou l'autre des gens qui sont totalement
débarrassé leurs problèmes de chômage en
fait vous n'en avez pas quand vous
regardez les états unis dont on croit
qu'ils se sont débarrassés de leurs
problèmes de chômage en fait ils s'en
sont pas débarrassés
quand vous regardez la fraction de la
population adulte qui a un emploi
elle est inférieure aujourd'hui à ce
qu'elle était en 2007 mais il ya un
artefact statistique qui fait que pour
ne pas être chômeurs aux états unis il
faut que vous soyez juste pas déclarés
comme étant en recherche d'emploi donc
si vous vivez dans la rue on ne
déclarant pas que vous cherchez un
emploi
vous n'êtes plus dans les statistiques
du chômage en france c'est pareil en
france pour être chômeur il faut être
déclarés comme étant en recherche
d'emploi sinon vous êtes inactif par
exemple les femmes au foyer
pas sexy ce que je suis en train de dire
parce que en l'occurrence est
essentiellement elle que ça concerne qui
ne se déclarent pas en recherche
d'emploi ne sont pas dans les
statistiques du chômage
elles sont dans une autre catégorie qui
s'appelle inactif comme les étudiants
soit dit en passant est comme les
retraités donc une bonne manière de se
débarrasser des chômeurs c'est de mettre
les gens en formation
à ce moment ils deviennent en études
donc inactifs pour être chômeur il faut
pas être en train de suivre des études
et déclaré qu on cherche un emploi
rappelez vous de ça parce que ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on résout nécessairement
tous les problèmes en ayant moins de
chômeurs ça peut juste vouloir dire que
des gens qui voudraient un an
loi ne se déclare plus comme étant en
recherche tout simplement parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'incitation à se déclarer
comme étant en recherche en france vous
en avez une
cette pris en charge par la collectivité
aux états unis vous en avez zéro
donc il ya plein de gens qui en
cherchent qui juste déclare pas qu'ils
recherchent donc le chômage apparaît où
les touristes de travailleurs pauvres et
à partir de 2006 à ce moment vous avez
une baisse de la quantité de croquettes
pour machines disponibles par personne
et à ce moment c'est double effet kiss
cool crise financière date qui explosent
et actuellement quantitative easing
c'est la création monétaire on n'en faut
absolument partout inflation des actifs
qui commence à se généraliser taux
négatifs qui apparaissent et problème de
chômage qui est toujours pas plus
résolue qu'avant un peu mieux mais
fondamentalement pas beaucoup plus là ça
explose
là ça se rétablit un peu macro n'y est
pour rien tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment sur le chômage
c'est les trouveurs de sol américain
c'est le fait que l'approvisionnement
pétrolier ayant recommencé à augmenter
en europe grâce à la hausse des prix du
pétrole et à la frénésie trou entre
gainsbouriennes de nos amis américains
les croquettes pour machines ont ré
augmenter donc l'emploi à un peu
réaugmenter macro n'y est absolument
pour rien et hollande sur la fin de son
mandat non plus mais le jour où ça
repartira dans l'autre sens il sera pour
rien non plus du reste l'évolution
structurelle de long terme est piloté
par l'énergie et à très court terme
parce que les gens sont en ville et pas
ailleurs
parce que les usines sont là et pas
ailleurs parce qu'on a construit le
système comme ceux ci il n'y avait pas
autrement et que les gens habitent à 25
bornes de leur valeur
emploi et pas et par ailleurs à très
court terme on ne peut absolument rien
faire pour que le système se comportent
différemment
et en plus de ça nous allons avoir un
petit sujet avec le client alors le
climat non évidemment le problème est
réglé
vous avez christina figueres qui à
l'époque était secrétaire général de la
convainc du secrétariat de la convention
cadre des nations unies sur le
changement climatique qui regardent d'un
air fois ci il est admiratif et d'amour
et j'en sais rien bref laurent fabius
transformée en commissaire priseur d'un
jour à battants son joli marteau vert et
déclarant l'accord de paris adopté
on va voir si ça a changé quoi que ce
soit l'origine du problème
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique la voici alors petit rappel
la terre un climat depuis qu'elle a une
atmosphère la terre à une atmosphère
depuis quelques milliards d'années
vraisemblablement originalement dues au
volcanisme donc ça fait un petit moment
que la terre à un climat comme jupiter
un climat mars à un climat étaient venus
à un climat dans l'atmosphère terrestre
vous avez des gaz sur tant de gaz les
plus courants sont l'azoté l'oxygène
mais vous avez un certain nombre
d'espèces qui sont présentes en beaucoup
plus petites quantités et dont certaines
ont la caractéristique de pouvoir
intercepter les infrarouges terrestre la
terre comme tout corps chauffer au
dessus de 0 kelvin émet du rayonnement
c'est le rayonnement du fameux
rayonnement du corps noir que vous avez
appris en physique et à la température à
laquelle est la terre la gamme de
fréquences dans laquelle la terre et
metz et des infrarouges lointains
parce que la terre est aux alentours de
300 calvin et à ce moment là vous
émettez des infrarouges lointains un gaz
à effet de serre sa définition est très
précise c'est un gaz qui a physiquement
la propriété d'intercepter ces
infrarouge l'a dit autrement c'est un
gaz qui possèdent des transitions
électronique dans sa molécule qui sont
exactement à l'énergie des photons
infrarouges lointains émis par la
surface de la terre
d'accord c'est sarah gaz à effet de
serre donc c'est un gaz qui a des
transitions électroniques qui sont dans
la plage d'énergie des photons émis par
la terre dans l'infrarouge lointain
c'est donc des gaz qui sont présents
pour certains dans l'atmosphère
terrestre depuis très longtemps
à commencer par la vapeur d'eau présente
depuis il ya de l'eau sur terre
pas exactement combien quelques
milliards d'années et eux le gaz le gaz
carbonique qui lui est présent depuis le
début de l'atmosphère terrestre
puisqu'il est apparu par volcaniques ce
qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment c'est pas que les sommes créés de
l'effet de serre ou directement ils ont
pas créé l'effet de serre l'effet de
serre existe depuis très longtemps
ils sont en train de l'augmenter dernier
petit rappel l'effet de serre est connu
depuis deux siècles on doit joseph
fourier en 1800 j'ai jamais 6 et 24 ou
26 à chaque fois j'oublie parce que je
crois que c'est 26 22 22 l'effet de
serre le l'article que fourie a publié
sur l'effet de serre je soupçonne que
ces 26 alors si c'est pas 26 et 24 et je
confond toujours avec une autre date qui
est la première exploitation du gaz de
schiste aux états unis à fredonia sur la
côte est pour faire de l'éclairage
municipal
donc le gaz de schiste est aussi connue
depuis deux siècles donc en 1824 26 je
ne sais plus fourier publié un papier
remarque générale sur le fonctionnement
de l'atmosphère est un truc dans le
genre et des systèmes planétaires un
truc dans ce genre là où il dit il ya
dans l'atmosphère quelque chose qui fait
que la température est plus élevée
que si ce quelque chose n'existait pas
alors 1820 quelque chose
les gaz à effet de serre ont été
identifiés les principaux gaz à effet de
serre ont été identifiés au milieu du
19e siècle par pouilles et indal et
enfin c'est à la fin du xxème siècle que
arrhenius fait le premier calcul d'ordre
de grandeur en disant ce qui se passe si
on double co2 dans l'atmosphère
en 1896 donc tout ça est connu depuis
longtemps
alors tant les gaz à effet de serre que
l'homme rajoute et qui vont perturber le
fonctionnement naturel du système on
ad'abord du co2 ce co2 est obtenue sans
grande surprise par oxydation du carbone
et où est-ce qu'on a du carbone à oxyder
dans tout ce qui brûle donc dans les
combustibles fossiles charbon pétrole et
gaz ça émet des gaz à effet de serre
dans la déforestation qui est
essentiellement de la bâtie brûlis donc
vous couper la forêt vous l'a brûlée
pour faire place à des surfaces à
vocation agricole et on verra un peu
plus tard que c'est essentiellement le
reflet de la croissance de la
démographie et de l'augmentation de la
part carnet dans l'alimentation
vous avez les cimenteries alors les
cimenteries les émissions de co2 des
cimenteries sont pour un tiers
l'utilisation de l'énergie comprend pour
chauffer les fours
pourquoi est-ce qu'on chauffe un four de
cimenterie parce que dedans vous mettez
du calcaire caco3 et vous chauffer
jusqu'à avoir la rupture de la liaison
seao d'un côté et co2 de l'autre donc en
fait une cimenterie un four de
cimenterie
c'est un endroit où vous chauffer à plus
de 1000 degrés comme dans les
indestructibles plus 2002 du calcaire
caco3 pour faire d'un côté de la chaux
vive que vous allez mélanger un peu de
poudre de perlimpinpin et faire le plein
caire pull ciment et de l'autre côté
vous avez du co2 qui fout le camp dans
l'atmosphère dont vous avez un double
effet de production de co2 avec
l'énergie de chauffe du four et dans le
four parce que vous casser de calcaire
en deux morceaux et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le ciment pour ceux d'entre
vous qui ont déjà manipulé du ciment à
mains nues c'est très agressif pour la
peau essentiellement parce que ça
contient un dérivé de la chaux vive et
la chaux vive c'est pas un truc qui est
très sympathique pour la peau
un autre gaz à effet de serre donc
absorbant les infrarouges intéresse
c'est le méthane le méthane est le
résultat de l'activité bactérienne
bactérienne pardon de bactéries
primitives qui s'appelle les arcs et que
nous trouvons dans des contextes
anaérobie soit donc en l'abri d'oxygène
de l'air au fond des marécages par
exemple donc le méthane c'est le sexe
qui s'enflamme spontanément dans les
marécages et qui fait les feux follets
dans les rizières qui sont des marécages
artificiel dans les estomacs des vaches
nantaises ou pas parce que vous avez de
la fermentation à l'abri de l'oxygène de
l'air dans l'exploitation des
combustibles fossiles
parce que ce méthane a également été
fabriqués au moment où les combustibles
fossiles ont été fabriqués sous terre et
donc quand vous exploitez du charbon du
pétrole ou du gaz
vous avez du méthane qui peut s'échapper
vous voyez que j'y viens vous avez ici
donc là cette courbe des émissions et
vous voyez que absolument rien de ce que
nous avons pu revendiquer comme
innovation technique ddt a infléchi
cette évolution est en particulier un
truc qui aujourd'hui est présent dans
tous les esprits
donc non seulement les renouvelables
mais le digital n'a pas plu s'infléchit
cette évolution que le reste donc mettre
les gens dans les bureaux
ça n'a rien changé à l'évolution mettre
des ordinateurs partout pour soi-disant
dématérialisée là strictement rien
changé à cette évolution non plus et si
ça n'a rien changé à cette évolution
c'est probablement que les ordinateurs
sont pas dématérialisée et quand vous
regardez c'est effectivement ce qui se
passe
cet ordinateur là il a fallu maîtres de
l'ordre de une tonne de co2 un peu moins
en 3 500 kg et une tonne pour le
fabriquer ce qui veut dire qu'il a fallu
brûlées cent cinquante kilos de
combustibles fossiles pour fabriquer ce
machin qui pèse un kilo et demi dans
lequel il ya quarante métaux différents
donc l'ordinateur dématérialisée je vous
fais grâce de l'expression célèbre de
zazie dans le métro marche pas le une
bonne partie vient de l'énergie mais pas
tout le co2 et en oxyde le co2 est une
molécule chimiquement stable comme tous
les oxydes sur terre tous les oxydes sur
terre sont des molécules chimiquement
stable donc si vous ne leur apporter pas
de l'énergie pour changer de forme les
oxydes sont des molécules éternelle ça
reste sous forme de clip ce qui veut
dire qu'une fois que vous avez mis de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
il n'a pas envie de s'en aller
spontanément et il ya deux processus qui
lui permettent de s'en aller qui sont
des processus de contact avec la surface
et des processus lent le premier est un
processus de vase communiquant avec
l'océan qui fait que co2 se dissoudre
dans s'il ya moins de co2 dans le sait
entre dans l'atmosphère mais c'est des
vases communicants
c'est physique et le deuxième processus
est un processus de photosynthèse en
faut de l'énergie
c'est en de thermique pour un photon et
c'est un processus qui ne se produit que
à la surface de la terre là où il ya de
la végétation
résultat des courses après arrêt des
émissions dont concret avec les
émissions un surplus de co2 dans l'air
parce que le co2 chimiquement inerte
sauf épuration après arrêt des émissions
ce surplus va progressivement ces purs
et donc les pluies vont progressivement
en reprendre une petite partie mais cédé
processus qui peuvent saturer et donc le
résultat des courses c'est que après
arrêt des émissions au bout d'un siècle
vous avez encore 40% du surplus que vous
avez créé et qui est toujours au dessus
de vos têtes
enfin pas les vôtres parce que vous
serez mort au bout d'un millier d'années
20% du surplus qu'on a créé il sera
toujours au dessus des têtes de nos
descendants s'il y en a et web ou de dix
mille ans 10% du surplus qu'on a créé
sera toujours au dessus des têtes de nos
descendants
s'il y en a
dit autrement vous n'avez pas de
réversibilité dans le processus du
changement climatique et il ya quelque
chose qui est impossible en matière de
changements climatiques
c'est l'idée de remise du système en
l'état le climat de l'an 2000 a disparu
à jamais du temps qu'il y aura des
hommes
voilà jamais on ne reverra le climat de
l'an 2000 soit dit en passant à cause de
l'inertie du système le climat de l'an
2020 sans aller aussi parce que quoi
qu'on fasse dans les 20 prochaines
années la dérive va continuer et donc le
climat de lambil de l'an 2020 va
disparaître à jamais aussi du temps qui
aura des hommes il ya une inertie
absolument considérable dans cette
affaire qui se joue sur des packs temps
qui vont au delà d'une vie humaine alors
que de l'autre côté la société se gère
sur des pattes tant qu'ils sont beaucoup
trop court pour que nous soyons capables
de mettre en oeuvre des solutions qui
sont pertinentes en face du problème
alors là je vous parle des élections il
ya encore pire il ya les comptes
trimestriels et la cotation en continu
des entreprises c'est encore pire donc
la financiarisation de l'économie dans
les entreprises cotées et les comptes
trimestriels
c'est une absolue catastrophe pour le
sujet que je suis en train d'évoquer
alors est ce que monsieur fabius a servi
à quelque chose malheureusement non vous
avez ici la quantité de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
depuis lors il se trouve que c'est une
coïncidence depuis l'année de ma
naissance
donc au moment où je suis né il y avait
un peu moins de trois cent vingt
millionième de co2 en volume dans
l'atmosphère et aujourd'hui on a
quasiment 420 et vous voyez sur ce
graphique dont graduée en année où ont
pris place quelques grandes étapes des
négociations climat vous voyez que ça ne
change rien donc en fait les
négociations climat ne sont pas des
négociations ce sont des discussions
climat y a rien à négocier
tout simplement parce que dans
l'enceinte des nations unies il n'y a
rien à négocier vous ne nous ne fait
qu'entériner ce que les pays sont déjà
prêts à faire il accorde paris est un
succès parce qu'il formalise simplement
le fait que vous entériné ce que les
pays sont prêts à faire dans le cadre de
l'accord de paris vous avez des
contributions volontaires
et on dit c'est un grand succès parce qu
on permet aux gens d'avoir des
contributions volontaires bigdil les
contributions volontaires comme c'est
volontaire ou les avait de toute façon
donc ce que fait l'accord de paris c'est
juste de comptabiliser le fait que les
gens sont prêts à faire des choses et
dans les choses qui sont prêtes à faire
il y en a plein qui disent qu'ils sont
prêts à augmenter leurs émissions
vous en avez plein d'accord et donc on
dit c'est un grand succès non ça ne
changera donc ce que je vous dis da
c'est que ce qui se passe dans cette
enceinte onusienne ne changera pas le
cours des choses
c'est un non déterminant sur ce qui va
se passer plus tard
l'initiative devra venir d'ailleurs
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles ça ne
change rien c'est qu'il ya pas de maître
du monde
donc y'a rien à négocier puisque a pas
de maître du monde voilà y'a rien à
négocier
est ce qu'on parle de quelque chose de
méchant quand on parle de changement
climatique la réponse est oui
vous avez ici une carte qui vous
représente l'europe alors non pas
actuelle j'ai pas eu le temps de changer
mais l'europe au début du 20e siècle si
on ne supprime pas les écosystèmes qui
s'y trouvent pour faire des choses
essentielles comme le campus de
centrales et des choses plus accessoires
comme des chants etc
donc vous avez à ce moment là des forêts
ce qui veut dire que vous avez des gros
espèces végétales qui sont capables de
pousser et donc un climat qui est pas
hostile du tout au contraire assez
favorable et en particulier à ses plus
vieux on se rend compte en ce moment
voici l'europe ya vingt mille ans alors
ya vingt mille ans je voulais dit le
climat était quelque chose qui date sur
terre il ya quelques milliards d'années
il a varié facteurs parfaitement naturel
de variation dont les paramètres
astronomiques de la terre qui change et
à cause de ces variations climatiques au
quaternaire vous avez notamment dr
glaciaires des moments où il fait
beaucoup plus froid que maintenant et
des airs plus chaudes qui sont celles
par exemple qui ont permis le
développement de l'humanité sédentaire
il ya vingt mille ans on est au coeur
d'une dernière ère glaciaire et à ce
moment l'europe ne ressemble pas du tout
à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
d'abord erasmus en suède vous oubliez on
oublie aussi soit dit en passant le
problème des centrales à charbon
allemandes ya pas d'allemand et ça
simplifie les problèmes et le tournoi
des six nations est passé à cinq nations
et la coupe 26 n'a pas lieu en écosse
puisque les écossais sont sous la glace
vous avez également les canadiens qui
sont sous la glace
le groenland a grossi l'antarctique un
peu aussi pour faire tous ces gros
glaçons on a prélevé enfin la nature a
prélevé dans l'océan énormément d'eau et
le niveau de l'océan du coup et plus bas
de 120 mètres donc vous n'avez pas la
mère à nantes à nantes vous avez une
communication territoriale continue avec
les affreux anglais qui ne peuvent pas
faire de break site puisqu'il ya pas de
frontières et les paradis fiscaux des
anglo normandes n'existe pas puisqu'il
ya plus de manches pour céder collins
compliqué de faire des paradis fiscaux
sur les collines le climat est beaucoup
plus froid donc il est beaucoup plus sec
dans un climat plus froid il ya moins
d'évaporation donc moins de
précipitations et les écosystèmes
maigrichon qui lie à l'époque en europe
parce que ils ressemblent à ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui au nord de la sibérie
sont mollement capable de faire une
petite fraction de d'une classe d'âge
étudiante dans ce pays vous avez cent
mille personnes dans ce pays qui court
derrière les mammouths et les airelles
pour être capable de se nourrir quand
l'europe est passée de l'état de gauche
à l'état de droite ça s'est fait dans le
cadre d'une planète qui se réchauffe et
bien évidemment sous des sous un procès
avec un processus parfaitement naturel à
l'époque qui est un changement de
paramètres astronomiques de la terre
provoqué par l'attraction de jupiter et
saturne comme depuis toujours et bien ce
cette élévation de température
planétaire qui a débouché sur ce
changement d'environnement
ces 5 degrés en dix mille ans c'est pas
5 de grippe par an pendant dix ans
évidemment ces cinq degrés au total en
dix mille ans dit autrement au 05 degrés
par millénaire
dit autrement 0,05 degré par siècle
c'est-à-dire en première approximation
100 fois moins que ceux dont on est en
train de parler en ce moment sous le
coup des activités humaines alors je
vais maintenant détaillé très rapidement
parce que l'heure tourne quelques
conséquences possibles de cette affaire
mais la première qu'il faut garder en
tête c'est que un tel changement de
conditions environnementales à une telle
vitesse si on a quelques degrés en un
siècle
au surplus sur une planète qui va
progressivement manquer de moyens de
faire face à n'importe quel
perturbations c'est à dire des
croquettes pour machines parce que c'est
à ça que nous sert les croquettes pour
machines
c'est aussi à faire face à n'importe
quel imprévu de manière beaucoup plus
confortable que si on les a pas la
raison pour laquelle un ouragan fait
cent mille morts au bangladesh et 1500
morts aux etats unis c'est parce que
dans le deuxième cas l'énergie abondante
permet de faire venir les forces de
l'ordre la nourriture d'évacuer les gens
de reconstruire rapidement les maisons
etc
alors que dans le premier cas de figure
les gens restent dans l'eau croupie et
meurent du choléra donc l'énergie c'est
ce qui permet de sa [ __ ] de faire face à
n'importe quoi et bien une planète qui
verrait les conditions environnementales
déstabiliser aussi rapidement pleinement
une humanité dans un monde aux
ressources qui vont progressivement
devenir contrainte
la chose qui va se passer partout c'est
le retour de la barbarie
ça ça va dynamiter les systèmes
démocratiques la paix et la capacité de
chacun à se nourrir en abondance dans un
environnement sympathique donc on est en
train de parler de la guerre partout on
ou alors c'est de la tecktonik
ça se met progressivement en tension
puis de temps en temps ça pète alors
quelques conséquences il y en a une que
les étudiants du manifeste connaissent
bien parce que c'est une carte qu'ils
aiment bien celle là
ici vous avez le nombre de jours où les
conditions extérieures empêche quelqu'un
en conditions normales de rester en vie
parce qu'il fait trop chaud et trop
humide et donc vous ne pouvez pas
évaporée en transpirant et vous mourrez
d'hyperthermie dans un monde dans lequel
la température a augmenté de 4 degrés
voilà donc on aura réglé le problème de
la déforestation indonésienne y aura
plus d'indonésiens soit dit en passant
c'est pas sûr qu'il reste beaucoup
d'enfants autant à ce moment là quand
même
deuxième conséquence vous allez modifier
dans le cadre d'un climat qui se
réchauffe la circulation à large échelle
sur terre qui est celle qui règle les
ceinture tropicale de part et d'autre
avec de part et d'autre des zones où il
pleut plus c'est à dire la ceinture
équatoriale et les moyennes latitudes et
hautes latitudes vous à les exacerber
cette affaire dans le cadre d'un climat
qui se réchauffe avec des zones où il
pleuvra plus mais aussi des zones où il
pleuvra
et vous voyez que la france est aux
avant-postes de la zone qui va le plus à
sécher dans la sphère c'est à dire le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
donc je peux vous assurer que quand les
gens auront plus assez à manger dans
porteur du bassin méditerranéen
le printemps arabe ça sera une vaste
plaisanterie en comparaison de ce qui va
se passer
et évidemment vous allez avoir des
mouvements migratoires évidemment vous
allez avoir la porte les gens n'ont pas
à bouffer en général ils déplacent les
soldes vont s'assécher et donc les
rendements agricoles vont se mettre à
baisser en moyenne sur une terre où par
ailleurs il paraît que la population
doit augmenter alors moi je ne sais pas
encore comment tout ça va se conjuguer
en général la nature a trouvé une
régulation qui marche très bien pour les
populations animales quand elles n'ont
pas de quoi bouffer ça s'appelle la
famine et à ce moment là population
diminue ici vous avez l'évolution de la
surface cultivable par personne
depuis que je suis née en gros et vous
voyez c'est passé de 26 hectares à 0 6
ha alors c'est pas un problème parce
qu'on a les tracteurs et les engrais
mais le jour où on a pu les tracteurs et
les engrais se passe quoi ce que nous a
dit le giec dans le dernier rapport
changement climatique et terre dont je
vous invite à lire les résumé pour
décideurs et soit dit en passant les
résumé pour décideurs des rapports du
giec devrait être obligatoire dans le
cadre de la scolarité de tout étudiant
c'est que à partir de trois degrés de
réchauffement vous avez de l'insécurité
alimentaire généralisée sur terre donc
vous aurez de la violence partout parce
que l'insécurité alimentaire entre
affamé n'a point d'oreille me rappeler
de ce quand les gens ont faim vous
pouvez pas leur faire entendre raison
la capacité des forêts françaises a
brûlé est aujourd'hui particulièrement
élevé enfin à la fin du xxème siècle
était particulièrement élevé sur
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
la corse est
raisonnablement en aquitaine et en 2040
voilà ce que ça sera donc voyez la
latitude de nantes
vous aurez la même propension des forêts
a brûlé que ce que vous avez en
aquitaine à la fin du xxème siècle et la
forêt de fontainebleau pour ceux d'entre
vous qui l'aiment bien brûlera également
enfin la même proportion à brûler que la
forêt aquitaine à la fin du xxème siècle
les phénomènes extrêmes vont se
renforcer et ils vont se renforcer pour
une raison très simple c'est que
l'interception des infrarouges terrestre
près de la surface par un surplus de gaz
à effet de serre diminuent la quantité
de rayonnement qui peut être intercepté
par la stratosphère
pour se réchauffer en provenance de la
terre et donc dans le cadre du
réchauffement climatique vous allez
réchauffer la températures près de la
surface mais la refroidir dans la
stratosphère
donc vous allez augmenter le gradient de
température entre la surface et la haute
atmosphère et donc augmenter la
puissance de la pompe convective qui met
en route tous les phénomènes extrêmes
donc c'est logique que dans un monde
dans un monde qui se réchauffe vous ayez
plus de tornades avoir plus de cyclones
et ouragans c'est la même chose et les
modèles ne le disent pas mais moi il
paraît logique que vous allez aussi
avoir des orages plus violents et des
tornades plus violentes
un orage comme vous le savez arrivants
n'était pas ce qu'on est et c'est là que
vous avez le gradient maximale de
température entre la surface et la haute
atmosphère
le groenland a commencé à fondre et la
fonte va s'accélérer quoi qu'on fasse à
partir de maintenant pour des raisons de
rétroaction positive
il va y avoir entre trois et six mètres
dos en plus dans l'océan mondial à cause
de ça dans le siècle à venir
l'antarctique de l'ouest est à risque de
déstabilisation java légèrement comment
ces glaciers de twente
parce que l'antarctique de l'ouest est
un vaste château de cartes de glaciers
arc bouté les uns sur les autres
l'ensemble étant posé sur un socle
rocheux qui est sous marins et en
déclivité
donc tout ça est instable dans un climat
qui se réchauffe avec une mer qui monte
et qui se réchauffe aussi et si
l'antarctique de l'ouest transforme en
un groupe d'icebergs
ce qui est tout à fait possible à
l'échéance d'un siècle où quelques
siècles
ça vous fait si m dos en plus pour
l'océan mondial à l'échéance de quelques
siècles par ailleurs la dilatation de
l'eau ce que l'eau qu'on chauffe cette
île at va également engendrer une hausse
du niveau des mers
donc si vous mettez tout ça boutabout
dès que l'on franchit les deux degrés de
réchauffement ou plus exactement des
comptes sur une trajectoire qui nous
amène au delà de deux degrés de
réchauffement en 2100 ce qu'on est parti
pour faire
eh bien vous mettez probablement en
route la machine infernale qui fait que
1 à quelques siècles plus tard l'europe
du nord ressemblera à ça il n'y a pas
que l'europe du nord
la floride bangkok shanghai est c'est
enfin toutes les villes côtières
les villes ont souvent été bâti en
bordeaux tout simplement parce que c'est
là que vous avez un moyen de
communication efficace en énergie qui
s'appelle le transport maritime et quand
elles n'étaient pas bâtie en bordeaux
elles sont souvent bâtis sur une rivière
exactement pour les mêmes raisons
quasi totalité des villes européennes à
quelques très rares ici une exception
près sont traversés par un fleuve parce
que c'était la voie de communication
permettant de transporter les pondéreux
avant que on avait des camions et des
trains l'océan va s'acidifier pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont lu jules verne
c'est l'acide carbonique le co2 donc
quand vous le mettez dans l'eau ça
acidifie longue ça vous libère quelques
proton qui se baladent et cette
acidification de l'eau alors l'eau
restera alcalines dans l'océan mais
cette acidification de l'eau donc la
diminution de la qualité est quelque
chose qui va handicaper la synthèse du
calcaire pour tous les organismes
notamment le plancton qui a besoin de se
fabriquer des coquilles en calcaire et
ça ça va évidemment être un facteur de
pression supplémentaire sur la vie
marine
outre le fait que l'on pêche trop et
qu'on s'installe à plein d'endroits où
on devrait pas vous allez également
avoir une modification de la circulation
océanique à large échelle alors ça ne
vous fera pas le jour d'après en une
semaine mais ça peut vous le faire en
quelques décennies
ça ne fera pas non plus une glaciation
de l'hémisphère nord mais ça fera un
déstabilisation en gros ça va
probablement si ça arrive rendre
beaucoup plus continentale le climat de
l'europe de l'ouest avec des saisons
beaucoup plus contrastée parce que ça ne
sera pas tempéré en toute saison par un
apport de chaleur qui vient des basses
latitudes
vous allez avoir de nouvelles maladies
qui vont apparaître
parce que quand vous chauffer le
bouillon de culture les petites bêtes
aime bien ça dont vous avez notamment
des maladies endémiques de zones chaudes
qui sont en train de remonter vers les
pôles
on voit ça avec la dengue on voit ça
chez des animaux la maladie de la langue
bleue et c'est évidemment là il est à
personne n'est capable de faire le moins
de scénarios prédictif là dedans
personne n'est capable de vous dire en
2034 vous aurez une épidémie che par
quoi qui va tuer les trois millions et
demi de personnes
aucun sens par contre il va y avoir un
facteur de pression supplémentaire qui
va venir de là vous avez d instabilité
dans le système lié au fait que des
stocks de carbone qui sont immobiles
depuis des milliers des millions
d'années vont être remis en circulation
d'un système par des premières
déstabilisation et là c'est pareil très
difficile de savoir quelle est la limite
supérieure et enfin c'est la dernière
phrase la plus importante
vous n'avez pas la possibilité de tout
prévoir
ne demandez pas à la science de tout
prévoir elle en est incapable
parce que le système est beaucoup trop
complexe beaucoup trop non linéaire il
va aller s'aventurer sur des plages
jamais exploré jusqu'à maintenant et
donc la seule certitude qu'on peut avoir
c'est qu'on aura des surprises
et comme le dictionnaire est bien fait
une surprise c'est quelque chose contre
lequel vous n'avez pas contre laquelle
vous n'avez pas eu le temps de vous
prémunir puisque vous l'avez pas vu
venir
donc la seule conséquence pas la seule
oui la seule chose certaine dans cette
affaire ces hackers à mesure que le
temps passera et que la déstabilisation
augmentera nous aurons une quantité
croissante de coups qu'on n'aura pas vu
venir à l'avance je vous le dis c'est la
tectonique des plaques
le truc se met en tension puis de temps
en temps ça fait boum et safra boom de
manière croissante dans un nombre
d'endroits croissant et de façon de plus
en plus surprenante pour une partie
je vais finir maintenant avec quelques
éléments qui vous concernent plus
directement et en particulier je vais
finir avec un an deux choses lui fit
d'abord avec ça et ensuite de finir avec
des choses qui vous concernent plus
particulièrement qui et quels métiers
dans cette affaire vous avez ici un
deuxième graphique qu'il est très
important de garder en tête qui est la
contrepartie physique de l'objectif des
2 degrés dans vous avez évidemment tous
entendu parler
donc quand on parle d'un objectif de
degré de quoi on parle
vous avez sur ce graphique un certain
nombre de simulations qui sont reportés
avec des dates mais en fait ce qu'il
faut comprendre de ce graphique
essentiellement c'est que il vous dit
que la réponse en température du système
climatique est essentiellement une
fonction de la quantité cumulée de co2
qu'on mettra dans l'atmosphère d'ici à
2100 donc dit autrement ce qui compte
avec la baignoire atmosphérique
c'est pas le fait que le robinet soit
plus ouvert au début plus ouvert à la
fin est terrassé juste la quantité
totale d'eau qu'on va rajouter
exactement la quantité totale de co2 qu
on va rajouter ça suffit à être capable
de faire une projection
donc plus on rajoutera de co2 d'ici à
2100 plus l'élévation de température du
système d'ici à 2100 sera forte
à fin 2010 8 nous avons mis dans
l'atmosphère les hommes et les femmes
2002 1250 milliards de tonnes de co2 et
donc nous avons déjà signé pour 1,5
degrés de réchauffement qui sont déjà
embarqué dans les émissions passées donc
c'est pas la peine aujourd'hui de
s'engager quand on est une entreprise à
être 1,5 degré compliance être 1,5 degré
compliance quand on est une entreprise
ça veut dire qu'on est capable d'opérer
en arrêtant demain matin la totalité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de la
supply chain
c'est ça que ça veut dire 1,5 2 1 donc
en gros ça veut dire qu'on fait + 1
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires donc une
entreprise 1,5 degrés aujourd'hui c'est
une entreprise qui s'engageait à ne plus
faire un drôle chiffre d'affaires demain
matin j'en connais pas beaucoup
si on est deux degrés eh bien on
renverse le raisonnement vous savez le
gros avantage de droite c'est que ces
objectifs enfin sauf rappel sont
horizontales et verticales laissez pas
le cas
et donc nous avons droit au total à 3000
milliards de tonnes de co2 d'humanité
dont 2250 ont déjà été émises alors même
les gens pas très bien réveillés dans
cette salle arrivons à faire 3000 de
moins de 1250 ça fait 750
il se trouve que c'est très exactement
le tiers de 1250 et le charme de cette
année 2018 ce qui veut dire que si on
veut respecter les 2° collectivement on
a encore le droit à deux mètres dans
l'atmosphère le tiers de ce que nous
avons mis jusqu'à maintenant et qui a
permis au pouvoir d'achat d'exister aux
retraites d'exister aux études longues
d'exister aux gens d'habiter en ville à
la campagne etc et de partir à l'autre
bout du monde pour 50 euros ce qui nous
a permis tout ça on a encore le droit
pour les 80 ans qui reste au tiers de ce
qu'on a et vit jusqu'à maintenant
oui on n'est pas rendu 1
on est un peu moins rendu dans les
promesses politiques
ça veut dire dit encore autrement que
d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon âge puisque
dans cette salle en gros vous avez une
vingtaine d'années un peu plus et que
moi j'ai malheureusement passé le demi
siècle où heureusement ce rien pas tout
et bien d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon âge
il faut que les émissions planétaires
soit divisée par 3 alors si vous savez
pas ce que ça donne comme baisse
annuelle demande est excellent il vous
donnera la réponse pour vous et excel
vous dise et - 4% par an donc un
programme politique qui est aligné deux
degrés une entreprise qui est aligné
deux degrés c'est une entité qui est
capable de survivre dans un monde où les
émissions planétaires baisse de 4% par
an et donc les croquettes fossiles pour
machines baisse de 4% par an c'est ça
une entité devrait alors je vous pose la
question est-ce que vous pensez que
l'état français y est la réponse est
évidemment non est-ce que vous pensez
que l'état français a compris ce que ça
signifiait la réponse est aussi
non il n'ya pas un ministre et un préfet
qui comprend ce que ça veut dire
si je fais un tout petit peu de règles
de trois là dessus et ça va être presque
le mot de la fin
voilà une petite règle de trois qui
permet de comprendre la difficulté
d'exercice est ce que ça implique comme
contrepartie donc marach de 3 elle est
basée sur quelque chose de très simple
qui est que les émissions de co2 sont
égale à elle-même jeudi visent eux
multiplient à droite par l'énergie
utilisée par les hommes pour les
croquettes énergétiques utilisés par les
hommes donc là c'est combien je mette
co2 dans l'atmosphère ce qui apparaît la
part croquettes énergétiques disponibles
je multipliais je divise par le pib dit
autrement par la quantité de biens et
services qu'on a à notre disposition est
donc là je fais apparaître une un
facteur qui est de combien de croquettes
énergétique j'ai besoin pour faire une
paire de lunettes une machine à laver ou
me déplacer de 10 km et enfin jeudi
viser je multiplie par la population qui
est aussi quelque chose qui existe sur
terre donc ce que je dis c'est que les
émissions de co2 sont proportionnelles à
la population fois la quantité de trucs
et de machins et de bidules que la
population à part personne fois la
quantité de croquettes énergétique par
truc machin ou bidule qu'on a produit
fois la quantité de co2 qu'on a craché
dans l'atmosphère par croquettes
énergétique et maintenant je dis à
gauche faut diviser par 3 dans les 30
ans qui viennent
alors vous savez que le grand charme
d'une égalité c'est que les deux termes
restent égaux de chaque côté voilà c'est
à ça que ça sert
alors maintenant on peut disserter
qu'est-ce qu'on va diviser par trop à
droite
première option on divise la population
par trois ça s'appelle une épidémie à
ces échelles de temps ça s'appelle une
épidémie la famine la guerre ça suffit
pas la guerre c'est ça si c'est
suffisant si ça provoque des épidémies
et des famines mais sinon ça suffit pas
ça suffit à créer des conditions de vie
très désagréable pour tout le monde mais
ça suffit pas je vous rappelle que la
grippe espagnole a plus tu es de monde
que la guerre 14-18 et plus vite donc la
grande peste du moyen-âge sas a divisé
la population par deux en parler d'un
truc sérieux
donc si on prend les projections
démographiques et j'insiste sur le fait
qu'il s'agit d'une projection et pas
d'une prévision
une prévision c'est vous signez avec
votre sang et vous êtes sûr que c'est ça
qui va se passer
donc moi je signe avec mon sens sur où
sera la terre sur son orbite dans 50 ans
ça je veux bien pas de problème
sur combien il y aura personne sur terre
dans 50 ans sûrement pas enfin dans 50
ans je peux signer serait mort mais donc
ce que vous voyez là c'est la projection
donc on dit ça ça doit diviser par 3 et
là on commence par x 1,25
donc vous êtes d'accord avec moi que les
trois termes restent en jeu doit
collectivement les / 3,75 alors une
deuxième option c'est de diviser par ce
facteur là la quantité de trucs et de
machins que nous avons à notre
disposition c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
prévoit pour sauver les retraites pour
sauver les retraites on prévoit que la
quantité de trucs et de machins vont
augmenter de 1 2% par an hélas à nouveau
excellent vous explique que ça vous
augmente sa d'un facteur quasiment 2 à
un facteur quasiment 4 donc c'est vous
dans cette salle là qu'ils allaient
devoir faire le job parce que qu'est-ce
que ça fait un ingénieur ça diminue la
quantité de croquettes énergétique par
trucs et machins fourni à la
collectivité et ça diminue la quantité
de co2 émis dans l'atmosphère par
croquettes énergétique
donc en gros a refusé de discuter de ça
et de sarah la collectivité vous dit
vous dans cette salle là vous allez
faire tout le boulot
rigolez pas c'est exactement ce qu'on
dit vous dans cette salle vous allez
faire tout le boulot
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous allez essayer de gagner au maximum
en efficacité énergétique et vous allez
essayer de gagner au maximum en contenu
carbone de l'énergie sauf que quand vous
regardez la tendance des dernières
années
on y est absolument pas ce qui veut dire
soit dit en passant que le jour où le
problème fini par se résoudre contre
notre volonté parce que les combustibles
fossiles baisse tout ce que nous ne
ferons pas là et là se fera là et là
c'est juste une équation
voilà ça à la froideur d'une égalité
évidemment comme je le disais tout à
l'heure les baisses là hélas
involontaire l'expérience montre que
c'est jamais extrêmement soft comme
transition et j'en profite également
pour vous dire que la seule différence
que vous avez entre la sobriété et la
pauvreté tels que je lançais niamey
étudiants c'est que dans les deux cas de
figure c'est récessif parce qu'il ya
moins de trucs et de machins
mais dans le premier cas on l'a souhaité
et gérer et dans le deuxième cas on se
le prend sur la figure sans l'avoir
désiré donc la pauvreté c'est une
limitation subi la sobriété c'est une
limitation désir et notre cerveau
primitif soit dit en passant est câblé
de telle sorte que le premier c'est
vachement dur à mettre en oeuvre et dans
cette affaire-là le lança je vais passer
parce qu'on n'a pas le temps ça je vais
passer aussi ça je vais passer aussi et
ça je vais passer aussi et je vais venir
directement à ce qui peut vous arriver
dans la vie je vous laisserai les
planches vous regarderez sa tête reposée
puis je dis toujours la même chose vous
avez d'explication ailleurs voilà dans
cette affaire quel est le lien entre ce
que vous allez faire la fin de votre
formation et
le problème que je viens de vous
présenter et bien je vous le redis là où
la société vos flèches de manière
préférentielle c'est de vous occuper des
croquettes énergétique donc les
croquettes énergétique peuvent concerner
ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité
énergétique
alors qu' elle n'est pas excessive si
vous arrivez à faire circuler vente
produire autant de voitures qu'avant
avec moins d'énergie
c'est par excessif c'est davantage mais
il va peut-être falloir malheureusement
aussi vendre et produire - dont vous
avez toutes les croquettes qui sont là
qui sont des trucs qui sont j'ai envie
de dire
non après il ya des trucs qui sont un
peu plus exotiques et en particulier il
ya quelque chose qui peut être le fait
d'un ingénieur d'eau venant économistes
mais pas des économistes à la sauce
moderne
enfin la sauce ancien plus exactement
qui racontent n'importe quoi il ya un
domaine dans lequel on va avoir besoin
de cervelle dès aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas soit dit en
passant alors c'est pas facile de
trouver un job parce que les économistes
classiques veulent pas qu'on s'intéresse
au sujet c'est comment on organise au
mieux la société si elle manque de
moyens dit autrement la gestion de la
pénurie pour appeler un chat un chat la
gestion de la décroissance pour appeler
un chat un chat non pas au sens où aller
souhaiter mais au sens où elle n'est pas
évitable et quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui est un champ de recherche
totalement vierge dans le monde
économique
dit autrement tous les économistes de la
terre se disent attendait bougez pas on
va tourner le potentiomètre des
prélèvements obligatoires du machin des
droits de douane etc
le pib reviendra donc ils sont à côté de
la plaque la bonne question c'est s'ils
pib revient pas comment est-ce que
j'organise mon système au mieux et
comment je minimise le sentiment
d'injustice
commenge optimise au mieux la
répartition de la population sur le
territoire
comment je prends soin au mieux des gens
qui vont le plus trinqué dans cette
affaire et c'est alors ça c'est un champ
de recherche totalement vierge et à mon
avis c'est un champ de recherche qui est
absolument essentiel pour que on est un
tableau de bord pour être capable de
piloter la descente
exactement comme on a eu un tableau de
bord pour piloter la montée vous avez
également un autre sujet qui est de
s'occuper de limiter la population
autant qu'on peut parce qu'il est
évident que sur ma planète qui fait
toujours 13 mille kilomètres de diamètre
plus on est nombreux autour de la table
et plus les ressources non renouvelables
disparaîtront plus vite
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe en afrique
quand on pleure sur les éléphants c'est
juste le résultat du fait que la
population augmente et qu'il n'y a pas
la place à la fois pour les éléphants et
pour les hommes
donc on tous les hommes prennent la
place des éléphants
tu vois c'est aussi simple que ça si on
aime bien les éléphants il faut
s'occuper du problème des sommes donc là
vous avez un grand sujet également c'est
un débat très difficile très difficile
parce que notre cerveau primitif est
câblé pour qu' on n'est pas du tout
envie de débattre de ce genre de trucs
mais plus on les vitres j'ai envie de
dire et plus mal on se portera
vous avez également une catégorie dans
laquelle une partie d'entre vous
tomberont malheureusement qui est de
faire croire qu'il n'ya pas de problème
alors vous avez plein de manières de
faire croire qu a pas de problème je
vois ça aujourd'hui partout dans le
monde économique dans les manières de
faire croire qu'il ya pas de problème un
premier truc qui va très bien c'est
d'attirer l'attention de la presse sur
les trois personnes qui s'agitent du bon
côté pendant que les dix villes qui
restent dans l'entreprise s'agit du
mauvais et s'agit de plus en plus du
mauvais bonjour j'ai un truc qui marche
très très bien
variante pendant que j'installe les
supermarchés en banlieue dans ma commune
je plante une éolienne en disant
regardez l'éolienne exactement pareil
ces mêmes procédés devine machine
deuxième procédé de greenwashing c'est
tout ça tourne autour de la confusion de
20000 un deuxième processus de
greenwashing c'est confondre les
échéances temporel donc comme l'a dit
notre cher camarade elisabeth bornes
il n'y a pas très longtemps c'est pas
très grave de faire le quatrième
terminal à roissy parce que le transport
aérien peut augmenter de façon en 2035
les avions voleront à l'hydrogène
si elle est prête à parier la totalité
de son épargne compte la mienne je parle
quand elle veut et vide à ça donc à
paris sur un pari et réaliste sur
l'avenir c'est une deuxième manière de
faire du greenwashing
vous allez trouver puisque l'avion à
hydrogène c'est vous qui allez mettre au
point ce n'est pas elle vous allez
trouver de quoi faire en sorte que la
fusée ariane se transforme en avion
commercial à bas prix ça existe déjà
refusé l'avion hydrogène s'appelle la
fusée ariane
voilà c'est un one way ticket tu es
c'est pas le même prix donc le sait une
deuxième technique de
de greenwashing une troisième technique
de greenwashing consiste à limiter les
calculs à là où on peut faire quelque
chose en ignorant là où on ne peut rien
faire et aux problèmes augmentent alors
je prends toujours un exemple un centre
commercial un centre commercial la
d'activité que parce que vous savez
fabriquer les produits les faire venir
avec des camions faire venir les clients
en bagnole etc
si vous dites à qui veut l'entendre j'ai
diminué les émissions de ma chaudière
grâce à de l'efficacité énergétique
grand bien vous fasse c'est un
déterminant totalement anecdotique dans
l'ensemble des émissions qui vous
permette d'exister jette un truc que je
vois très couramment etc
voilà donc il ya un autre truc sur
lequel il va falloir être vigilant et
quand vous sortirez de formation vous
aurez pas nécessairement les moyens de
l'être c'est d'éviter d'être mis au
service de gens qui vont vous demander
de faire du greenwashing et j'insiste
quand vous sortirez de formation ça ne
sera pas nécessairement trivial d'éviter
les pièges
voilà donc je m'arrêter là
merci beaucoup pour les interventions on
va maintenant passer autant de questions
réponses
on va devoir faire vite donc je vous
prierais d'être concis dans les
questions et les réponses
puisqu'on va finir à midi
donc on va voir en deux parties un micro
ambulants pour qu'ils s'y poser des
questions ici et des questions posées
depuis l'envié s sur ordinateur donc
n'hésitez pas surtout c'est maintenant
ou jamais bonjour je vous remercie pour
votre intervention et j'ai bien aimé le
concept des croquettes pour machines ce
que je trouve ça très accessible moi qui
suis pas du tout ingénieur moi je me
présente sur une liste sur une petite
commune dans le vignoble de moins de
10000 habitants donc si j'ai bien suivi
votre raisonnement ça peut être
pertinent surtout qu'on est dans la zone
maraîchère et je voulais savoir pour
vous si l'échelon local c'était un
échelon pertinent d'intervention et
qu'elle pourrait être une ou deux
mesures intéressantes à mettre au
programme des municipales qui sont dans
un mois merci à tous les échelons sont
pertinents dans cette affaire et aucun
est suffisant donc tous les discours
politique qui consiste à dire l'état est
incapable laisser faire les communes les
collectivités locales et c'est ce qu'on
entend de temps en temps ce sont des
discours qui trouve pas valide parce que
à tout le monde doit avoir sa part qu
est-ce qui est valide à l'échelon local
l'aménagement de la circulation
l'urbanisation ou là des urbanisations
donc l'affectation des surfaces
l'information on peut très bien
organiser localement la répétition
l'exercice de ce matin juste pour que
les gens comprennent voilà c'est vrai à
la fois pour les électeurs et c'est vrai
pour l'équipe municipale puisque le
fondateur de la fresque du climat est un
voisin vous pouvez très bien faire faire
une fresque du climat au conseil
municipal nouvellement élu voilà donc
ces cd vous avez un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont de l'ordre locales ce
qui n'est pas d'ordre local c'est la
réglementation sur les produits
c'est pas vous qui allez faire la
consommation des voitures neuves ce qui
n'est pas d'ordre local c'est le réseau
électrique
c'est pas vous qui allez faire la
planification globale du réseau
électrique
voilà donc un certain nombre de trucs
qui sont pas d'ordre local et un certain
nombre de trucs qui sont d'ordre local
essentiellement sur la partie
circulation et vous pouvez également
avoir quand vous êtes dans une commune
suffisamment riche la possibilité
d'inciter les gens à s'occuper de la
performance thermique de leur logement
soit en mettant des oeuvres mettant en
oeuvre des dispositifs de type
inventaire améliorer donc pas le
diagnostic de performance énergétique
mais ce qu'on appelle le passeport
énergétique par dessus un chiffre soit
en créant localement des filières de
rénovation qui permettent aux artisans
travailler correctement quand toujours
gagné d'avancé et deux aux gens en face
de faire appel à eux au moment où ils
doivent le faire de façon pertinente
j'ai une question d'un certain yann
guerrier théâtre aujourd'hui face à
l'urgence climatique et la puissance des
détenteurs d'intérêts carbonées la
désobéissance civile était le seul
recours c'est un débat auxquel il ya pas
de réponse simple quand vous regardez
l'histoire il ya eu des tas de périodes
dans l'histoire ou la désobéissance à ce
qui était la loi du moment est considéré
avec le regard de l'histoire comme ayant
été le comportement légitime quand de
gaulle a dit je ne reconnais pas le
gouvernement français on l'a fini par
lui tresser des lauriers pour avoir fait
ça donc la question de la désobéissance
civile
pour moi elle est très liée à l'acte qui
est fait dit autrement respecter la loi
n'est pas nécessairement la chose la
plus intelligente à faire
par contre c'est pas parce qu'on ne
respecte pas la loi que nécessairement
on est dans le vrai donc c'est peut-être
une réponse un peu vague mais le fait de
après à chacun s'il a envie ou pas de
prendre des risques voilà on peut aussi
aller faire un sit in sur une autoroute
je considère que le fait d'attirer
l'attention sur un problème comme ça est
quelque chose qui reste légitime tant
qu'on ne provoque pas des problèmes qui
sont plus graves que celui qu'on essaye
de résoudre
bonjour donc dans la salle n'y a pas que
des inactifs ya aussi des gens qui dit
travail sur le site et notamment qui
essayent d'enseignés voire de faire de
la recherche est parfois dans des
domaines qui sont à l'opposé de ces
autres vient de parler donc comment
typiquement adapter les enseignements
qu'on pourrait avoir faire donc on a vu
au début de la de la matinée là une
pétition qui dit que dans toutes les
options il doit y avoir une partie des
cours dédiés à la transition écologique
est ce qu'un inverse
tous les enseignements y compris
scientifiques doivent se justifier à
l'aune de ces observations alors se
justifie à l'aune de ces observations
non être en cohérence avec ses
observations oui à condition que ce soit
la volonté de la collectivité
donc en fait moi mon rôle ici il est pas
tellement de vous dire occupez vous du
problème ou ne vous en occupez pas il
est vous dire comprenez bien ce que vous
faites si vous en occuper ou pas donc
mon sujet est un sujet de mise en
cohérence
si je résume ce que je viens de vous
raconter en une phrase ceux où on
souhaite se mettre au régime et à ce
moment on met les enseignements en
cohérence avec ça donc on apprend à se
mettre au régime
intelligemment ou bien on dit on s'en
fout tant que ça dure que ça dure et si
on s'en fait péter la panse
on s'en fera péter la panse et à ce
moment il ya aucune raison de mettre les
enseignements en cohérence avec ce que
je viens de raconter mais on a là pense
qu'il finira par péter donc le voilà
c'est une affaire de
moi mon message aujourd'hui il est dire
faut qu'on comprenne bien ce qu'on veut
et à partir du moment où on a choisi
l'ordre dans lequel on voulait traiter
les choses
à ce moment il est souhaitable de mettre
les problèmes enfin le les enseignements
en cohérence avec ça donc si on
considère que la paix par exemple c'est
plus important que le résultat net de
n'importe quelle grande entreprise
à ce moment on s'organise de telle sorte
pour que la contrainte carbone soit
supérieur s'impose à l'économie dit
autrement à centrale nantes
vous avez droit à tant de tonnes de co2
pour fonctionner dans l'année point et
puis si ça ne vous permet de recruter
que tant d'élèves et pas plus et pas
vous recruter tant d'élèves et pas plus
voilà un exemple si on décide que c'est
ça la règle à ce moment il faut mettre
les enseignements en cohérence et donc
il faut apprendre à calculer le carbone
plus que calculer les euros et c'est
finalement si on décide que c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fonctionne dit autrement
vous recruter de plus en plus d'élèves
chaque année vous les envoyer aux quatre
coins du monde et dans ce cadre là qui
est considéré comme supérieur on voit ce
qu'on arrive à bricoler sur le co2 c'est
pas la peine d'essayer de mettre les
enseignements en cohérence avec ce que
je viens de raconter parce que façon
vous y arriverez pas donc il ya un vrai
problème de choix et comme l'a très bien
dit un économiste de mes amis décidé de
s'occuper sérieusement du problème de
climat un choix moral ça relève du bien
et du mal
ça ne relève pas d'une rationalité ça
relève vraiment du bien et du mal et
d'un choix moral
bonjour merci si vous étiez le ministre
de la recherche ou encore mieux si vous
aviez les moyens de bill gates
quelles seraient vos principaux
investissements pour sortir de cette
galère
et est ce que vous diriez être
incollable sol og je sais qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui s'inspire de vos travaux
merci alors là de la réponse à la
deuxième question je vais l'évacuer
parce qu'il faudrait définir de manière
normatif ce qui est un collègue se
loguer ce n'est pas le faire donc
par contre je peux vous répondre que
j'ai essayé d'attirer votre attention
sur un truc qu'il n'évoluait pas dans le
bon sens
le la réponse à la première question
alors je vais pas vous donner je vais
vous donner quelques éléments pas
beaucoup je pense que quand vous êtes en
économie de guerre ou un logique crash
programme vous supprimez toutes les
forces de frottement qui font que les
gens passent leur temps à faire de la
paperasse plutôt qu'à utiliser leurs
cervelles donc dans le domaine de la
recherche je supprime la nr je supprime
les appels à projets je suis primes etc
je prends des gens intelligents motivé
je leur fais un chèque en blanc et je
les laisse chercher
en gros c'est ce que je ferai avec des
éléments de cadrage qui sont en nombre
limité et quand vous regardez la
recherche qui a eu lieu pendant la
dernière guerre mondiale il y avait un
cahier des charges très simple trouvez
moi tout ce qui permet à notre armée
d'être supérieure à celle d'en face
simple vous emmerdez pas les gens à leur
demander de vous remplir des dossiers en
45 exemplaires et a justifié à l'avant
ce qu'ils vont trouver et vous leur
botter le cul pour qu'ils aillent le
plus vite possible
c'est exactement ça qu'il faut faire
voilà donc je vous réponds ce processus
après les thèmes précis il ya tout ce
que la société fait aujourd'hui donc que
ce soit dans l'agronomie la technique
l'aménagement du territoire etc
mais voulant donner un cahier des
charges simple et pas les emmerder avec
des problèmes accessoires
bonjour alors je voulais revenir sur
quand vous avez parlé des retraites nous
et que je vous ai entendu exprimer votre
accord avec les propositions de gaël
giraud pour le développement en afrique
qui devrait se centrer seulement sur le